all right if we are live the last word
with Laura Cognito and ivontas on that
Friday night campfire action a little
little special guest right we got
something going on yeah we got a good
man in here
um let's just bring him in right now not
skipping over anything so let's get
right to it get to it welcome to the
last word episode number 119. it's
another glorious Friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
looter shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so we
gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord who's not
only a rising star as a young content
creator but it's definitely the epitome
of pure entertainment
whether it be his informative weapon
breakdowns PC streaming builds and
exotic raid help all done within our
destiny community
introducing the creating host of the
MiFi YouTube and twitch channels my
fellow warlock scholar Lord of recluse
who correctly recognizes Vault of Glass
is one of the top movements in Destiny
live from Kentucky and making his debut
at the campfire of the last word mommy
Lord my father how you doing sir I'm
doing good man
that was one heck of an intro
[Laughter]
what's going on man good to have you man
at the campfire man good to be here good
to be here no doubt no doubt no doubt so
uh um I know we got a lot going I'm
gonna let you get into the beginning
parts of the questions we got we got a
lot of stuff to ask you so you can check
out for me
he admitted
I'm muted there you go I was letting
everything come in so he's like okay
yep what you got man uh well uh my fight
I just wanted to for one thank you for
coming on I know you reached out being
like dude how do I get on a podcast we
got you on obviously I appreciate it
like honestly the destiny Community is
awesome about that because there was a
lot of people who love to talk about
Destiny and we all have a lot of passion
about it and I like what I was kind of
getting a little information on you how
the way you why you picked your uh class
of choice so tell us what your class of
choices and why what was like one of the
things that kind of got you hooked on
and obviously another point where it
completely saved your butt
uh so I remember it was a uh it was a
warm summer uh in between with some I
think it was in between my 10th 11th
grade year when uh Destiny one was uh
about to come out you're gonna make us
feel old dude yeah I I had not seen
anything on it
um I have never played Halo uh and
didn't I mean I knew about Bungie and I
was an Xbox guy but I kind of started
gaming after hey or after Halo uh
reached and all that stuff and one of my
friends is like you should look up uh
Destiny the beta is about to come out in
a few weeks so I look it up uh I watch a
few things on it
um I think I went to like GameStop
pre-ordered it paid my five dollars went
on my way with my beta code uh I get
home I redeem it I'm on the Xbox 360. I
think this was I I I think the next gen
I know we're getting really close to you
the new consoles coming out but this was
back when like the Xbox one yeah maybe
maybe uh I think the Xbox one had just
came out or it was about to come out
um
I get it on the 360. I redeem my code uh
I log into the character creation screen
um and I start looking through stuff I'm
like all right I'm I'm a very simple guy
you know uh I'm like okay human all
right mail and then I start looking at
like the classes I'm like all right
Titan
Hunter Warlock and the the first thing
that I saw was was uh
[Laughter]
and I I forget the exact description of
each class but I remember along the
lines of like Titans being like the uh
the like front line type uh you know
like first in like the the frontal
assault type thing uh and then I saw
like Hunters the the like the like
stealth of the battlefield or like
they're stealthy they uh quick clean
kills all that stuff and then I saw
Warlock and it was like magic like
reaching into the void and stuff and I
was like oh that's that's a hundred
percent what I'm going for any game that
offers any sort of magical characters
that's that's the character I'm choosing
I played Skyrim for probably like a
total of three hours I was not a Skyrim
guy uh and I went for like a magical
character so wow so like Diablo mage if
you played World of Warcraft you would
have been a mage but yeah kind of a
common turn there yeah yeah I really
want to get into World of Warcraft but
that's a scary thing to get into be
careful yeah yeah I'm I'm scared you
have an addiction with Destiny already
you don't need like an extra Albany yeah
if you get more than one of those you
may not see the Sun for a little while
and we're already fairly pale over here
so nah respect my father because
literally your story is how I chose
warlock it's literally the same thing
because I mean I usually tend to go for
characters like Titan so I'm actually
people are very surprised I don't pick
time class usually in other games I kind
of pick classes like that but it was
something about it was two things it was
like you said the description him
showing the you know the void or
whatever he's doing that look real quick
some little energy ball in his hand if I
remember it like he had control of it
and then the second thing shout out to
slo-mo in the champion Messi's warlocks
are the only class worth player salute
to you being messy man I'm at a
disadvantage tonight
I'm gonna
go ahead
we got love for the Titans and other
raids yeah man it was literally that and
I think for me the um the sealer
actually the only difference we have is
uh you pick human I went awoken because
I saw I just like the blue skin and they
were mommy I'm a huge Silver Surfer fan
so I was like yo we got like silver
serverless yeah magic thing going on so
it was pretty cool man that's what's up
cool yeah
no I and there for like the first like
years so of Destiny one I I didn't
regret it but I was like man I wish I
could do more for my team because I
remember like Destiny one like warlock
couldn't do anything for like anyone it
was like you ran self-res or you ran
like like
yeah right but like Titans they had
bubbles Hunters could uh like help out
with the team in some sort of way but
warlocks they they just kind of didn't
have uh anything but I'm glad I stuck
with it just because I truly believe
that uh warlocks are the best PVE
character right now which is mainly what
I play so
talk about it I mean you've got a cool
sort of reading the background like
you've got a really cool story as far
even though it doesn't exist anymore you
know self-res was a thing some friends
was a thing and you you've got a pretty
epic story in reference to self rest we
want to get into that that moment yeah
tell us where this was the the clutch of
clutches
so it was Vault of Glass it was still
year one I I don't think no no no yeah
uh I I think we were a few deal season I
think we might have been on House of
wolves um I if I'm not mistaken like I
was running with an lfg team normally I
would always have a few friends online
uh and then we would you know uh say hey
we want to raid so we need lfg to find
some people and this is back for like
the whole Xbox lfg existed when you
would have to like go on a website and
you know like find your things like that
uh your like other players that you
wanted to uh kind of play with and we
did the raid we were up till uh Atheon
literally the entire raid is just a
complete blur I don't remember any of it
but I remember this one specific
um
moment now
uh Atheon was a boss that could be
damaged outside of when you were
technically supposed to damage him it's
just you would do no you would do such
little damage without
um without uh times Vengeance that right
that was the buff
um so you would go into your portal you
know Future Past uh you would kill the
oracles and all that stuff while the guy
with the shield would you know be
protecting you and whatnot
um and then you would come out and then
at least how my team did it is that
everyone would go to the center like
little floating platform yes uh like
right before where the boss would stand
uh but in front of where the entrance of
the room was and it was completely like
it was kind of like a little island yeah
that's what we were doing damage from
and we were on like the third I think it
was like the third damage phase I
believe it was a phase before enragement
Oh and he had
such little health and I believe someone
in one of the portals missed an oracle
uh and everyone's screen you know
started turning I think yeah yeah yeah
and then so I knew in my head because I
had if if you got wiped due to oracles
involved you couldn't self-res it was
like a mechanic you just couldn't
self-res or at least as far as I
remember you couldn't so I remember that
and I remember thinking okay he
literally has such little Health that he
could be killed outside of uh
times like uh without the buff pretty
much right um so I jump off I die and
then the other two guys they were still
doing a little bit of damage but then
they got wiped and then I wasn't really
saying anything I self-rezed and then I
killed him that that's pretty much how
it went and it was probably like one of
the like everyone else in the in in the
group she's like oh whatever like they
didn't care but to me I was like yo that
was like
it was some lfg guys my friend's like
yeah that's cool but dude no one cared
and I was like I don't think you all
comprehend like the the amount of brain
power that that just took for me to
perform yeah for like five seconds of
like thinking coming up with a solution
then acting on it and then it actually
worked and I was just like oh my
goodness the disrespect
exactly wow like do you know no you
don't even know what I did for you
exactly listen man I would two things
one that fight people I know people
always give uh Vault a little low crap
because of nostalgia but that fight man
I really love that mechanic just the
splitting up of the two teams yeah you
know the time thing kind of cleansing
yourself the Oracle stuff get it back
and all I love the the aspect of all
coming back together to do DPS I think
that's someone one of the coolest things
and I remember that fight because I
would jump into that Island like you
said right yeah and shoot up so for you
to do what you did and then shoot him
outside of that time Vengeance you know
buff thing
clutch man and shout out to the self-res
wall locksmith oh yes sir we've saved
many a Nightfall many of raid you know
what I'm saying they had to stop us they
had to shut us down we were too powerful
they could not bring us back
D1 was self-res warlocks now we've got
invisibility Hunters doing all the
resting I don't know if the Titans are
ever going to have those we have some
bubble resist momentarily but not nearly
as often you guys did but the bubbles
always clutch man it's almost there when
you need it bubbles there always expect
a Titan with helmet say 14. I got so
much respect for y'all like y'all they
cover that bubble they blind they are
like respect respect and the weapons of
light respect you know there's always
certain classes you like yo I'm glad we
got that guy
for sure what else you got for about
five
oh me yeah you
uh just kind of bet your history a
little bit I know you did you've kind of
jumped around from everything from like
Pokemon and instead of in sports games
and Black Ops kind of like me I've
played so many different things over the
years uh I mean with you know some of
the Nostalgia stuff that comes out we
had like the Mario 35 anniversary come
up recently and then we also have like
the Zelda one like how far are there any
games that haven't been like either
remade or remastered or like anything
that you would like to see kind of you
know done in a recent generation or
anything that you like played before
would like to see again
my all-time favorite game
um and I kind of like to like separate
my games like my all-time favorite like
multiplayer uh game is of course Destiny
uh but I'm a massive single player
person like I love my single player
games
um and my favorite my my favorite single
player game of all time is Fallout New
Vegas
um people have tried
um going on the Fallout 4 engine and
like remaking pretty much the entirety
with voice lines and everything of
Fallout 3 and New Vegas and each one of
them always gets shut down by Bethesda
because they're too close to the
original and it I think it starts
infringing on copyright but if I had to
choose like one game that I could have
like come out within like the next year
or just get like an official uh it's
happening would be a remake for uh
Fallout New Vegas and then of course
Destiny one I would say yeah I would
love to see it like ported to PC but I
mean we're getting so much stuff out of
the destiny content Vault coming in
Beyond light that it's pretty much the
same thing no doubt I want to shout you
out on that that's a that's a huge gem
right there and um for Fallout yeah
people heavily regard that as the best
in the series I got into Fallout at
Fallout 3 then I had to play New Vegas I
realized how much better
yeah but um that's actually I realized
that's actually obsidian and that's when
I became a huge fan of obsidian
especially now at Microsoft Cinema
Studio because I didn't know they were
behind so many of the games I liked and
I'm like oh I just thought you know it
was the Bethesda banner and Bethesda
does everything and I didn't realize it
was actually done so salute to them and
um you might want to look into I don't
know if you tried uh out of Worlds have
you tried that I have not tried out uh I
was out of Worlds I've seen some things
on it I remember when it first came out
it had some like really negative uh
reviews and stuff but apparently since
then it's gotten really good you should
check it out manage it's your people
it's your people yeah
[Music]
um obsidian uh I remember right after
Fallout 4 came out because the first
three was made by Bethesda and then New
Vegas was made by City in and then uh
four was made by uh
um no Bethesda again and then people
were like well are we gonna go back to
obsidian and uh obsidian actually made a
statement that they were like we would
love to work on another Fallout game but
bethesda's just not letting us but if it
ever came up in the future but I don't
know how it is now with the whole uh
Microsoft being signed with them and
whatnot so it's probably not gonna
happen yeah now yeah they've got they've
got some stuff cooking um look out for
this game allowed it looks phenomenal
um kind of like maybe a Next Level take
on Skyrim and stuff like that and then
Auto worlds is still making new DLC and
stuff like that so yeah I still want to
know who managed to be like all right so
we've had our worlds had our Wilds outer
I'm sorry yeah who did that we chose it
first year like not that far apart could
not have been more confusing to be like
I can guarantee you some parents about
the wrong but the wrong game yeah facts
it definitely happened
absolutely man absolutely Yeah man so
don't think that's I think it's really
cool that a jet you do is very tech
savvy and I like the uh the PC kind of
breakdowns and fun again what got you
started on the uh the setup like the
streaming to help people get streaming
setups so uh that that was kind of just
like a one-off type video that I did a
few weeks back um I but I've always been
like a uh a kind of tech junkie in a
sense uh I remember like where I
originally found like uh like YouTube
was like off watching like unboxing
videos of tech and I've always been like
you know not necessarily tech savvy but
uh just like seeing like what's the nest
like what's the next best thing you know
um and then eventually I think it was
late last year I ended up building a
computer
um and I remember I got like all my
knowledge all my information from just
like you know people on YouTube that
like to talk about it Reddit forms stuff
like that I eventually built a PC uh
it's my current gaming one um and then I
built a friend's PC and now I've built
my streaming PC so that's three PCS
under my belt I've never had a problem
with them and it's it's it's it's it's
so fun to do it like it's so fun to
unbox a new one it's like my favorite
thing yeah I get to do it that often
you're like okay cool I got it set
hopefully this thing lasts me for three
years but I wish I could build one every
few months like yes it's so because yeah
I've built like three or four of mine
over the years I'm sitting here looking
at new graphics cards waiting on new
chip I've followed like all that stuff
and you can just go down like Chase too
soon this Linus like Hardware yeah you
can go down the tech tube or YouTube
lineup and I watched them all so yeah
I've watched those over so long and then
follow like what new hardware is coming
and all that type of stuff yeah PC
Building is an adult Lego that is yeah
no the Legos have lights on them and
they're colorful oh they're colorful
yeah man shout out to IFA get me back in
the game because I I've been so far
removed and he helped me with my setup
and so it's cool to see you know I
always feel it's cool to see content
creators do that because obviously this
is your field you want the you know to
optimize get the best at performance you
can with streaming and doing all the
stuff you're doing but you even broke it
down to other equipment and your other
setup and stuff like that and other
questions I had to ask you how excited
are you about these uh Nvidia these this
30 series yeah how much did you go and
that's over there about this I've
watched so much
adti owner I just want to make sure
everybody is okay I own a 2080 TI in the
main gaming rig and then uh I whenever I
built the streaming rig literally
everything was sold out it was either
sold out or double MSRP and I was like
with the new cards around the corner I'm
just gonna cheap out I think about a
2060. um
and I was like I'm I'm just gonna wait
for the new cards and then I'll take the
2080 TI as just a joke because you don't
need a graphics card that powerful
inside of a streaming rig that relies
off of uh your CPU so once they come out
and I get my hands on one I'm gonna take
my 28 TI throw it in the streaming rig
and then I'm gonna throw the new one in
there
[Music]
uh yeah just Asus is definitely one of
the best I have an egv EVGA uh 1080 TI
like for the win three and this thing's
been solid but mine especially I swear
they were talking to me when I was
watching the stream hey you uh 1000
series you could upgrade down it's like
yeah because I'm like I'm look all of
them are gonna kick the living crap out
of mind because the 3070 is as good as
yours
which is nuts and then the 3080 beats
that handle and the 30 90 is just an
absolute monster but yet still less than
a Titan cost this current generation
which only is About a Week longer which
is just it's so great like 50 people are
saying 1500 bucks is too much for a
graphics card and I'm not saying it's
not extreme believe me don't get me
wrong that's a crap ton of money for a
graphics card but the Titan being
24 2500 for the 2000 series Titan yeah
2500 and this thing's a thousand dollars
cheaper and just destroys that like it
never existed like 24 Giga Ram 10 000
Cuda cores I mean we're talking just
gobs and got I mean they're sitting
there now granted they were playing some
8K at 60 frames per second and I was
just like I don't I still don't know if
I believe what settings those were on
they said it looked pretty but we need
better way yeah either way there's a
whole lot of things that can change but
now like a 2090 or 30 90 playing like 4K
144 Hertz now those monitors that have
been like waiting in the wings at some
point you're gonna be able to use me now
is the time because now you actually
have enough power to use those pretty
easily
funny story about that I think um I I
don't know if you saw but I I recently
bought a 4K 140 for its monitor in prep
okay I bought it and it's like there's
there's very few monitors like with like
4K currently right now with the current
limitations of display Point 1.4 and
only being able to transfer I believe
like it's 30 some gigabits uh per second
um it's impossible to like push like
full 4K at 144 and uh like retain all of
your kind of color
um so there's a new technology uh called
like uh DSC which is I I forget exactly
what it means but um I think there's
probably I think I think there's like
two or three monitors right right now on
the market that has that have DSC and
the monitor that I bought actually has
it whenever I purchased this monitor
which was about a week ago
um Amazon had tons of them like I mean
tons of them I remember checking an hour
after the Nvidia cards were announced
there are 10 left and then I checked
like 20 minutes later and they were gone
they are completely sold out now and I'm
just like okay I was not meaning to do
that but thank God I did yeah exactly
because people are future proofing now
right everyone yeah so now now we're
gonna see can it run Microsoft's flight
simulator that's this that that is the
question that is the question how much
how pretty is a flight simulator gonna
look that game is beautiful
it's beautiful but it's like it it can
it's like the new crisis from what I
hear it's like how much can it make your
rig sweat completely just handily just
pour and sweat absolutely and it'll run
out your SSD your ssda main on that is
storage
I also heard it uses somebody was saying
it uses it's like constantly streaming
the like data of like yeah live weather
and streaming the information for like
all the maps and everything it's amazing
it's so cool yeah amazing Texas it's a
good time to be a gamer yeah it is it is
we're gonna get some pretty games and
potentially some consoles maybe yeah I
wanted to ask you that actually
um
Xbox PlayStation have you always been PC
do you lean anyway what are your
thoughts about this just this game of
chicken on this tightrope that at some
point is going to come to an end just
where are you standing on all this right
now I was just curious if you're like I
just spent like all this money on crazy
graphics card monitors you guys do you
I'm gonna be over here or if you grew up
on either one I was just kind of curious
so I grew up
um on the PlayStation one and eventually
the PlayStation 2 and then eventually I
switched off to the Xbox 360.
um played on the 360. yeah played played
played on the 360 and then eventually
Switched Off and got an Xbox One
um played on the Xbox one for all the
way up until
last year all the way up until last year
yeah yeah yeah and like that was the
only reason that I stayed on there was
my my friends were on there and I was
just like well it says I have like six
years on on here now I'm might as well
just keep it right uh but no it it
wasn't until this past year
um uh
whenever me and my girlfriend started
dating uh she had a PlayStation okay and
I was like hmm PlayStation I was like
I'm an Xbox guy it was contentious at
the beginning yes yes so I'm like you
know what I'll try this PlayStation
and then I just pulled out all these
awesome games and you're like all right
I'll marry yes yes and I like as someone
that loves single player games
when I got Spider-Man uh I started
playing through ghost of sushima uh The
Last of Us like and I was just like what
have I been missing this entire time so
I'm really excited for the PS5 I'm I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm praying I'm praying that
they give like an update in like frame
rate and Graphics to uh like go like uh
goes to sushima five comes out yeah it
comes out that new multiplayer Mill
comes out kind of around the same time
yeah
I think it's gonna be I'm really helpful
if I do bags Legends did you play God of
War
uh I have not played God of War I have
not I have never played a God of War I
had never played one before at all
that's the one just play that's the one
just play that one just play the music
I will give you little Snippets of like
history and honestly watch one of those
like God of War one through three in
five minutes like do one of those and
then just you're kind of you get the
general gist go play God of War amazing
so like yeah that's one more that you
gotta Play It's
why that's almost got to be my game in
the generation it's it's definitely in
like
way up there so it's it's amazing it is
amazing absolutely and like I said it's
such a departure from the others that's
why you can kind of jump in at that
starting point and like he said if you
just if you really want to know you
could do like a recap of the other game
because it's such a technical departure
and um yeah man it is truly uh give it a
shot yeah man yeah man I'll have to man
no doubt No Doubt
um what's we got for the man
uh I don't know uh you got anything for
him yeah I mean we got we got that we
got the stream in history I mean I think
for me what interests me about the
channel was obviously seeing like the
Pinnacle stuff kind of really helped
take take off for you and I just wanted
to get like some other key moments for
you in in streaming or whether it be on
YouTube that you really said okay you
know what
this is really jumping off I'm going all
out now you know what I'm saying like
well give me some moments that really
resonated for you whether it be YouTube
or or actually Twitch streaming
uh so YouTube of course I started uh and
it it was crazy how I started you know
it originally started as like a oh my
God I can't leave my house type thing
because of like uh you know I post High
School coming out of high school I uh I
was you know a very guy that was super
like you know cared about my looks and
stuff like that I went to the gym
everything like that and then post High
School I broke out with like acne and
stuff and uh so I pretty much just kind
of like I went on Accutane if y'all know
what that is uh like your my skin
literally burnt if I went in the Sun so
I was like you know what I'm just gonna
stay inside so I started recording like
videos and stuff and then you know it
kind of like snowballed here and there I
bounced around from like Call of Duty
fortnite and then I eventually landed on
Destiny
um I just moved out of my parents house
uh and where I lived prior I had never
had good internet like all my life
um I built a PC and uh I started kind of
um I wanted to get back into Destiny as
someone that was uh very uh attached to
their day one destiny character that I
made
on the first day of Destiny one's launch
I was like all right I can just cross
save it and use it and so I did that I
like when I say I was playing like 10
hours a day I was playing then more than
I do now
um I was playing 10 hours a day grinding
I mean I had like I played in year one
and then uh I I played year one I
finished the campaign and I did a raid I
was like all right cool and we all know
how year one was and then curse of
Osiris comes out I bought of course the
max Edition because you know just a
massive Destiny fan that I am and that I
was I bought the max edition of D2
um first DLC comes out graceful Cyrus
finishing like a day uh second DLC comes
out War mine same thing yeah uh at that
point I mean I was kind of just done I
was like you know what I'm just gonna go
off do other things I remember forsaken
came out and I got Forsaken and uh oh no
I played like the campaign I I finished
the campaign and then I was like you
know what I'm done so I had the entirety
of forsaken I had the entirety of all
the Forsaken DLCs to catch up on I mean
man I remember like grinding izanagi's
birdie from start to finish grinding all
those Pinnacle weapons from start to
finish trying to catch up on all the
raids trying to do literally everything
I gotta back you up though cause you
said something that broke my heart
so you you you did The Forsaken campaign
you a veg kid and the dreaming City
didn't wow you the dungeons The Last
Wish didn't keep the end like what made
you go away from forsaken none of my
friends were playing it I had no in the
raid with
um
I've been there at this point I had only
finished the red War campaign on one
character and this was back before I
think you could just skip the red War
campaign I I don't remember when they
implemented that in uh but I hadn't
finished that I had like I I felt like I
was so kind of
uh there was so much for me to do and
like I didn't know where to start yeah
that's true though that's a very valid
point with Destiny at that point yeah
they didn't do that was when me used to
talk about it they did a terrible job of
onboarding people who returned to the
game
and they yeah they try you know but I
agree it's still not it's a little bit
better now it's a little bit better now
but back then it was literally just a
whole bunch of icons and you don't know
who to talk what's what's priority you
don't know what you're supposed to be
doing first so I I will give you that
that is definitely something I can
completely understand where you're
coming from on that regard but continue
sir yeah
um
but no yeah I don't know what it was
that made me quit I think I was just
kind of at that breaking point of uh
I've played so much Destiny in my life
like I had thousands and thousands of
hours on D1 uh D2 year one just just
didn't hook me like you're one of
Destiny one did and I know like some
people like like to say that D1 year one
was
the worst experience than D2 year one
and I feel like there is this there is
this cycle that Destiny is in where the
first year which I know they're not
making it Destiny 3 but I was like okay
year one of Destiny one was okay it was
all right year two was amazing and then
same thing happened with D2 year one
it's all right right second year was
amazing but like I didn't really I don't
it's just something about like in the
third year is kind of like
yeah it's not as good but it's like hey
we're still we're better we're better
than we started yes let's just get let's
just get to the magic question since we
bringing this subject up
um so where do you stand as a totality
from d1's Total to D2 to where which
side of the camp are you staying on as
far as which Destiny is better for you
oh D200 wow
D1 is cool I love D1 but the amount of
content like if you put someone down in
front of D1 and you put someone down in
front of D2 and you're like play the
entire game do every single thing the
person
um it's I think it's completely
subjective and opinionated about which
one they might enjoy more but the amount
of content is undeniably more in Destiny
2. there's more to do
um
but in in enjoyment wise if I had if you
were to like wipe my memory and you know
I I was told to play D1 and D2 and tell
me which one that I thought was better
and say they were both at like the same
uh
you know I can play them on PC and all
that stuff I didn't play one concert one
on PC and all that uh
that's a hard one I I think I would
still stick with D2 looks I gotta
respect it man don't agree but I can
respect that yeah I mean I understand
this guy just lives in his Nostalgia
he's getting old living in his younger
years now we're not doing it we're not
doing that we're gonna stop that right
now because this podcast is in the
minority with a lot of stuff we can do
that poll we could do that oh
right now this is this is last do a lot
of people agree with you
no we got to do the Twitter poll we
gonna do the Twitter we're gonna take it
to the world we're gonna see where
people feel on that yeah shout out to
Ricky say Blasphemous but it's all good
now listen man I get his uh I get by I
do get your your point as far as um
content right and one thing D2 has done
really well is that consistent you know
drip of content yeah always something to
do you know kind of stuff and I get it I
completely get it it just comes down to
this is subjective all right at the end
of the day all this is subjective it's
all personal preference stuff like that
I think for me the reason why I stand so
on the other side is that I just feel
that D1 was a little bit more of a
hardcore leading MMO experience and that
yeah suited my thing also you know as
far as the end game mechanics and stuff
like that I don't feel that shout out to
the car is going by I don't feel that um
I felt like D2 really held your hand and
oh yeah 100 too accessible right and
then they had to find that happy place
and my last argument against each other
as much as I love where D2 is now I I
felt D2 there were way more moments
where I quit the game where I'm just
like this ain't it whereas D1 I felt I
didn't quit the game because the game
wasn't doing what I like I just stopped
the times that I did stop playing with
just like okay I've done everything now
I'm waiting for the next thing that's
how I feel so it's just a difference of
opinion but I would love to get a
Twitter poll on that and see you know
what I'm saying what's going on Destiny
2 73 Destiny one this this is the E
glass murder campfire
Channel
half this chat is my fire right now I'm
not even gonna pull in the majority at
this point now whenever you mention kind
of like the MMO kind of style RPG
experience I still think and not
necessarily that the way it was handled
but the grind right um of the leveling
system in year one of Destiny one was my
favorite thing in the world like I
remember this is back for light level
was introduced and I know a lot of
people hated it and don't don't like
don't get me wrong like the fact that
one level uh on day one of crota being
out like if you didn't have someone that
was level 31
um so say you had an entire fire team of
people that were level 30 you couldn't
beat crota like you couldn't beat him
day one you needed someone that was
level 31 as the sword bear because one
level like the amount of damage like the
amount more damage that you could
actually do was so significant I didn't
like that uh like the the whole okay
you're 30 but now you're 31 so now you
can hit the raid but I did love the
grind the grind to get those armor
pieces and to level up I remember
deleting so my day one warlock has
stayed with me but my other two
characters I remember deleting a warlock
and redoing Vlog seven times in one week
seven times and when I say like I think
it was like during a break or something
from like School uh I I played I was
missing gauntlets and I needed gauntlets
to be level 30 and like just just like
the obsession with I need to get this
and like the grinding that it took
because like you could only get at that
time like uh powerful gear from like the
raid or like the nightfalls yeah well
you had to like I think you had to do
the raid to finish it up because that
was like forever 29 or no yeah yeah
forever 29 was Vault of Glass and that
was just from doing the raid was that's
why that was that was why a lot of
people did raid and that's again where I
will agree with you on that piece is
like
the end game I'm not saying it's all I'm
saying peace
you don't even like paid him to agree I
love this continue
preaching sir and do you really get crap
for this from probably half of the
people who play Destiny's but like doing
in-game content is what should get you
to max level
they've kind of like lessened that one
to be a little bit but even the 10 power
levels by The Season's feet they haven't
quite and again I don't know if they're
gonna do anything this next coming
season season and I doubt it because we
already know what the numbers are like
for Infusion and stuff like that for the
future Seasons but the the way it was
like doing the end game that was why I
rated so much preach it is because
you've had to now it's like it is to
where there are a lot more options the
fact that like you can trip your way
through iron banner and get like the
plus two Pinnacles and again I haven't
even been a fan of that for a while and
I may get crap for it but it's like
Bridge brother preach that's just one of
those for me is any game that you go
through it's like the hardest stuff is
exactly that like the trial is Flawless
just needs the same treatment as like it
all that stuff needs to be hard to
achieve and not everybody's gonna get
everything exactly and again this is my
hardest biggest argument against D2 and
I love it I do I we literally come on we
love this game we love we love what he's
doing but my main disgusts are never
forget
what up D2 you do the red War campaign
and then you're like all right cool
what's the next thing and then you see
this Hawthorne character and I'm like
all right cool and I'll never forget so
I'm like yo we got to do this Leviathan
raid everybody in the clan let's go
right so we're doing it we don't Blood
Sweat and Tears we beat Calvin you know
Pimp Daddy callous with good experience
right I had fun and I'll never forget I
had like five people in the clan right
and they like yeah um I just went to
Hawthorne and I got midnight cool and I
got this and I'm like you didn't even
raids yeah yeah was eating and no one
raided and I'm like are you serious
they're like they gave you that and they
gave what was the rocket Lord sins of
the past yeah yeah it became the
participation trophy game so I'm just
like oh you're not going cheap in my
experience and then everybody's just
eating out here for free it doesn't have
to do any Pinnacle activity I was
disgusted like oh you gotta never forget
it because again people can say it's
bougie but I do agree with E the highest
end content the Pinnacle Inc that should
be the reward to get you past those
levels to make people engage in the
contest and then they just kept giving
you all these uh well if you're just
doing iron brand or four times you can
get right there with the guy that raided
and you you know and then we lost the
whole last point I was saying a little
tirade but the last one I'll say is that
um one of the key moment for people who
love wrath and machine as their favorite
rate I'll never fight them on one thing
I always felt the system wrath the
machine did as far as the little see the
key fragments as far as participation
and continually running the raid and
still able to um get the actual raid
gear and just very rewarding experience
because I always felt that's one of the
more fun ways to win and I just wish
other words were better in D1 pretty
much yeah
at this point so I guess I think where
the disconnect is is like if you're a
consistent Raider like how me addict and
a lot of guys with my clan are it hurts
still that they haven't kind of brought
those systems back you know what I'm
saying to to to to make it there that's
it but I agree with UE quality of life
of D2 is way better protection things
like that Bounty says turn things are
just way better quality I just want them
to get back to a little bit more of the
hardcore experience and hopefully we'll
see it with the uh the new subclasses
and stay since they're starting to get
there yeah
little more customizing and builds and
stuff like yeah to talk about which is
kind of intriguing that's yeah that's it
for me it's like there are certain
things about D1 certain things about D2
If I weighed them as a complete package
I think D2 tips the scale its direction
mostly on the fact like as you said the
breadth of content the fact that we had
you know we're on season 11 now we've
been through so many different stories
we had Ada we've had so many varieties
of activities versus a lot of downtime
some were better than others we had
unworthy we had Drifter not all of it
hit it well
um so it was like not everything's like
you know just sniffing roses but
I mean we've had so many cool like the
Menagerie yes amazing experience they're
launched with a raid that whole year of
forsaken was so much and they had
multiple Studios doing it but you know
D1 they were under the Activision Banner
as well and it's just there's but yeah
it's like raid raid loot this time
around especially
I want unique grade perks I want armor
that sets itself apart I want dungeons
to drop like zolmec armor so I look like
a Crazy Fire hydration yes and I want
like I want like if you solo Flawless a
dungeon like give me something that sets
me apart like a badass emote or
something I mean there's there's so many
things chatter White
that's a very small nugget of like stuff
that we are slowly inching back to
they're getting again ever versus had
its you know fingers in a lot of stuff
and they're slowly starting to pull him
back so it's this whole glowhoo yep both
of those I miss I miss I feel like d2's
raid legendaries are severely lacking no
they all mostly are because I mean you
have PVP Pinnacles you have right now
gnawing hunger is better than anything
you'll get in Garden of Salvation that's
what I'm talking about Last Wish like
gnawing hunger is kicking the crap at
every legendary gun that you're gonna
get in there yeah and it's a gun you're
getting like a box a box yeah it could
be Gambit engram who knows where you get
at this point it comes from everywhere
and it's just better than those and
unfortunately like yeah those are older
raids so I'm hoping like if deep Stone
[__] supposedly whatever it's gonna be
um doesn't have like raid exclusive or
any anything that helps
like intrinsic perks in any way at all
for that raid it's gonna make me really
really sad because yeah that's the type
of stuff they need I completely agree
like knowing hunger as great as it is
should have been like somehow like a
raid you know acquire I just feel the
legendary they made this shift where
it's very exotic dependent like single
exotic dependent in D2 race whether it
be the Anarchy the 1K and don't get me
wrong those are cool but I just I don't
feel any attachment to like when I get a
rage or outside of maybe midnight cool
sins of the past Leviathan I'm trying to
think of legendary they're going to set
rules that were good and it was a set
and now you can get same idea outside of
it good point and now that they went
random without any intrinsic perks to
the raid or that that's another thing
like there's really no raid weapons that
help with mechanics nope right
okay okay what you think my am I going
too hard on the television I don't like
uh I I was massively not I mean I wasn't
you know like pitchforks and torches and
stuff but I didn't like uh raid Exotics
that were only that like their special
perk was only useful in that raid like I
remember Vault of Glass for example had
that had had the perk where um the
Oracle you would do more damage to
oracles
um now the weapons in fog were still
really good uh but I would much rather
see raid weapons with uh Pinnacle style
um perks like example Master of Arms is
only found on recluse
um micro missile is only found on
mountaintop right like I feel like that
especially if they're only going to do
Pinnacle weapons what once a year now is
what they're saying uh if they're only
going to do Pinnacle weapons once like
go ahead and start you know like looking
at creating like you know very unique
perks that are only found on you know
that raid Scout or yes that raid pulse
rifle or that raid handcase and then you
know if you want to throw one like
underneath or if you want to make it
like the intrinsic thing right where it
it which helps out with something within
the rate and that's fine but I would
much rather have like a like like a
pinnacle Style special perk on it to
your point like we know regex is going
away right how cool will it be like for
example Desperado to come back within a
raid legendary you know what I'm saying
something like that would be great like
those Pinnacle level perks that are so
unique like I said you can only get it
from this subset of weapons and stuff
like that Desperado and a hand Cannon oh
my oh my good luck balancing that but
that's the point Destiny somebody's I
cannot remember where I heard it
recently Destiny is usually at its best
when it's near broken
it's when you have a lot of fun things
are a little off whether it be laser tag
or whatever it may be like that's a
prime example of just goofy fun but
there's a lot of times when things are
leaning towards broken because we've
been through the
balance everything into this little
nugget of year one Destiny 2 we are too
balanced everything's all the same it's
boring like now they're getting into
some cool stuff with Exotics but
legendaries can't always just be boring
yeah I mean yeah even gnawing hunger in
itself is like
I don't know what my role is right now
my subsistence Rampage it's still lots
of bullets and extra damage for three
years we've had some type of either fast
reload and damage and they haven't found
a way to like steer away from that and
they just gotta start I don't know I'm
curious we'll see what happens this fall
but the cool thing to your point is with
the introduction of sun setting I feel
they should be a little more Fearless
because it'll last just for a couple of
seasons and then intrinsically be sunset
so yeah I think maybe with that that'll
give them the confidence to get a little
bit more you know like you said like
feel is low like slightly all the way
broken but just have a little bit more
fun with it you know what I'm saying
speaking of stuff that's going to be
broken I think it's what the background
is in the podcast and basically
everything we got come in with stasis
so I honestly wanted to ask you guys
before we even get into like breaking
down the subclasses and stuff like that
how broken do you think stasis is gonna
be how how long do you think it's going
to take till people find like some game
breaking like situations or there's like
strategies that like Bungie didn't see
do you guys think they've do you think
they've thought outside the box enough
to test everything VA James just like
day one
uh I think that people are really gonna
find uh if there is anything to find
which more than likely there is uh
within space it's like cool maybe broken
things post raid I remember when last
wish came out
um no one ran well like with warlock
like no one ran it because it it was a
brand new subclass and they weren't
comfortable with it and people really
didn't start experimenting with well and
they didn't really realize oh my God
like it's it's like a bubble but I can
shoot out of it
um until post raids so I'm gonna go and
say that it'll be post uh if it is
called the Deep Stone Crypt once that
gets beaten um then that's when people
are really gonna start getting their
hands on stasis and uh like all like the
really hardcore players because of
course I mean the hardcore players are
going to be prepping
um for the raid and then once the raid
is done then people will start uh kind
of messing around with it but I'm
interested to see I know a lot of people
right now are kind of saying the whole
um or what I hear the most is the
grenades man the out of the map and all
that that stuff and I'm like Bungie's
gotta think about that and I I I don't
think I mean I think there'll be a few
things here and there that'll be like oh
my God like this is broken with the
whole like you know grenading and
platforming but I don't think it's gonna
be as massive as people are making it
out to be because I mean we already have
barriers and stuff like like out of
bound zones that will just tell you to
turn back and more than likely that's
what will happen with most of the people
trying to like discover glitches and
stuff of course I think that there will
be a few here and there that Bungie just
didn't think about or just you know kind
of got bugged along the way but
yeah that's kind of my thought on like
how long it'll take people to uh kind of
start using stasis and whatnot
not fair enough I mean I'm kind of with
you my five I'm gonna Reserve Judgment
at the end of the day I just love how
cool it is how out of the box thinking
it is
um I oh I'm always gonna applaud them
for the September slash you know full
expansions because to me those are
always the most transformative
experiences investing those are always
when like I get hyped sandbox changes
whenever you get new sub classes now
we're getting stasis this is just fun
stuff so you know it's just another you
know like another tool in the tool [__]
like you just we're gonna see what this
thing does we're gonna you know and like
you said it may be a little bit of
overreaction the only thing I'm a little
nervous I was nervous but concerned I
should say is PVP I gotta see how it is
moving PVP I gotta see that but it's one
of those things when it comes to a raid
I'm very interested you made a good
point like I remember in the beginning
you know I was like I didn't realize how
powerful well was I I didn't realize how
what what's our boots man what's our
boots that guy knows all the factions
baby you know what I'm saying so like I
didn't realize how serious that was you
know what I'm saying and then people
start to catch on and then strats start
kicking in and then you realize so I
think eventually people will find things
that you're like okay this is this is
serious but I think there will be some
times where Good Old Reliable yeah still
work whether it be you know Titan bubble
warlock well and so on and so forth all
I'm hoping for and we haven't got to the
hunter yet I know we don't do the hunter
this way but uh I really am pulling for
the hunters to get a true support
ability like yeah I know they like to
flip around
tether which is really good for a girl
yes you're right tether is fine take
that back you're all right with that I
meant to say uh class ability I would
love Hunters to get a supporting like
weak Titans you know well yeah I got you
yeah like I just want them to have
something that helps the team I feel
like they need something you know in
that regard
the invisibility grenade can be
beneficial beneficial for multiple
people yeah if you go that way to like
hey get out of a pinch that's how people
get through Grand Masters half the time
right now is invisibility grenades just
to skip stuff may not be as intended but
it's in there yeah I want something
intentionally so what would support it
that's I guess the thing about a hunter
though as it is it's still like the wall
and even if the new well that we can
free stuff which we'll talk about in a
little bit it's still a well so how
would you what would the Dodge do for
you that would support
I'm trying to think I mean it is a hard
thing because I know Laura Wise Hunters
are the lone wolf and you know kind of
you know about themselves Gunslingers
and all that stuff I get it I I can't
necessarily think of one but I'm
confident bungee could create something
that what you think about if you got
something in your mind that you think
they can do for hunters that like could
kind of I know those Hunters are in a
good place right now not that they're
not in a good place okay I'm just kind
of waiting to see like what stasis is
going to bring for hunters because I
know so far what we've seen is uh the
hunter
um at least I I I I know and I know we
haven't got the full kind of uh like
little mini teaser that they've done for
the Warlock on the Titan yet but I know
like from what we've seen though what is
it like Titans like their nades uh or
like their like little ability or
whatever causes like walls to form from
Ice and then Hunters calls as platforms
yes uh I I think that's gonna be
interesting but um no I really don't
have like I I don't even know what they
could do with 100 people maybe the
platform is
like the Titan throws the wall grenade
and that's the one that hits like in PvP
and goes vertical and then you got the
one in PvP that's horizontal I'm still
wondering about the grenades because
they're like the grenades when they show
the subclass
I guess we're just gonna jump into that
part
you have like the jumps and there's two
little gray scores underneath and be
like okay those are your other two jumps
you have your barricade for the Titan
there's one other box which would be
like rally barricade or the Towering
barricade and the grenades don't have a
little gray box yet in the trailer I
know a Titan is throwing the wall
grenade and then a hunter through a wall
grenade and PVP they both have so I'm
wondering if that was just a weird piece
of footage or if like each class gets
one stasis grenade which we'll dive a
little into more but yeah that's
interesting I'm just curious like I said
shout out to the hunters ain't no no
slander just you know just wanna know
what y'all doing
I'm honestly curious when it comes to
stasis if people can wrap their heads
around its capabilities I guess when it
comes to crowd control which is what it
sounds like a lot of this is going to be
not so much destruction but
like control slowing like freezing all
those things in a raid situation as you
guys talk about the people who put that
to use you know for defensive throw up
all over here freeze these guys over
here like defending the group like one
or two good stasis people are gonna be
like not quite healers but they're your
support crowd control while other people
are focused on what's ahead of you right
keeping you alive which like if done
well I will be curious if they're at all
involved as you guys said on the raid or
if they do start shining later I'll be
curious if it's one of those that gets
take advantage of yeah and my last point
with that I also feel with these kind of
powers implemented that it almost
suggests that overwhelming odds you know
what I'm saying that we're gonna need
stuff to control these enemies like like
stuff is just gonna keep on coming
because these are powerful abilities
y'all like these like stopping enemies
in their tracks and just doing all this
type of stuff so I'm very curious to see
the mechanics of the enemies that we
fight that we're gonna have to deal and
use a lot of these power so excited man
I'm pretty pretty hyper
well we may as well talk about them uh
let's get it we got uh get into it
two different stasis subclasses broken
down in a bit more detail we've got the
shade binder which is where we'll start
it's the Warlock uh we know we've got
Winter's wrath so this is my warlock
criminal let you guys take this one uh
you've got the shatter Shockwave which
is going to be the detonation from
actually the staff Crystal and then also
the penumbral blast which is your melee
but also seems to be like a function of
the super as well the projectile you
shoot out that freezes and then you have
your big explosion shock wave that will
shatter so wanted to get you guys
thoughts just on the two abilities see
what you guys are thinking excited not
excited where are you guys at on the
shade binder right now
oh
so for shade binder I
I'm still kind of on the fence about the
whole shatter one like m is just like oh
my teammate's free stuff and now I get
to shatter it like and at the same time
like can enemies that are Frozen only be
killed if they are shattered like that's
or like shattered or shot or
um that's kind of like where I'm still
like on the fence about like which one
is it I know the whole freezing
capability where you shoot the little
staff that's cool
um I am really really looking forward to
um the uh freezing riff though like that
is like one thing I am looking forward
to so much because he's lit there has
been like especially like challenges
like solo challenges or I like it just
keeps coming back to me whenever I
completed my solo prophecy for um the
way I solo Flawless for prophecy the
dungeon uh there was a point where uh
I like my strategy for like once you
know once like one side was dunked and
the ogre would spawn in Boss room I
would throw a rift down and one of the
biggest things that I always kind of was
concerned about is if I get overwhelmed
in that Rift so like before I would
throw that rip down I had to make sure
that I had devour up in case a thrall or
something like that would come in and
start smacking me up I could melee him
and then get my health back everything
like that stasis Rift where I can throw
it down and then anything around me kind
of just freezes stop that that gives me
a a a a window of opportunity especially
as a warlife that runs you know 100
recover I could recover like all my
health and be good to go and then I
could start you know I could be back in
the fight bro that's the main thing I'm
most excited about and I know it sounds
crazy because normally you know you
should be excited for the super and
stuff but I am really looking forward to
that question of which you bro I got two
Exotics for you Vespa radius okay and
sanguine Alchemy think about what that
could do with the um the stasis files
bro imma keep it honest with you man I
don't think I've ever used those like
big Exotics you know what it's cool let
me educate you
today okay
no so I was gonna say for you for saying
Alchemy that's the one where you extend
your Rift that's the one with the Riff
extended so here every time he gets
killed casting your Rift generates a
shock wave that freezes it's not a
continuous freeze so I know that's not
going to continue I know I'm just
letting you but I'm yeah I'm just saying
that once the freezing part stops and
you're still killing the basic Rift if
it heals right will still heal you for
example if I run storm coil right then
when I got my little Arc soles Right
Dark Souls are left I got sanguine on or
so as soon as the initial 10 seconds or
whatever is the Riff the axles will go
away right but the Riff stays down and
I'm just getting as long as I kill it's
almost like a devour you know what I'm
saying it's a people don't use it it's
very powerful and then Vesper would be
cool probably that's what probably work
better with the actual freezing because
you'll do the freezing right boom now
with more and the more enemies go around
you the more recovery and your riff
comes back so if you're overwhelmed with
Vesper based on the amount of enemies
around you this thing is going to be
powerful man I'm telling you people
people gonna start really I've given you
a game right now giving y'all again
people are going to start using those
two exotic I have a lot of functionality
if done right I'm very excited for that
Rift I'm with you man I think that Rift
is going to be very very very effective
very effective for me I mean look
shaybattle sounds cool I love the whole
let me get my Lord of the Rings let me
get my Gandalf on you know what I'm
saying I'm feeling that you know what
I'm saying and then um I think I I gotta
see how it works with the the freeze and
the chatter mechanic how that works if
I'm the person that can do it if I have
both the ability you know what vibe I'm
getting um yeah I think we talked about
it is Anthem I'm getting Anthem primer
and what you call them Detonator yes so
I'm getting that each class will have a
primer and a Detonator and one will be
that you know freezing and the other one
will be shatter and then where we
combine each class could combine again
while I did them now you do yours and
then we can really get cool because
that's one thing I know Anthem gets a
lot of crap but me and he always fight
for it and it says they did introduce
some cool things that they have no no
end game but they introduced some really
cool things and I think this is I think
this is Destiny still informative a
little bit what do you think I'm gonna
bring it back to you man after you
sneeze but um yeah I think I love this
ability I think this is really cool
I'm hyped man I'm hyped to see more of
it I'm hyped to see what other
functionality you got but what you got
you so for me on the Warlock I'm kind of
with my fight on the fact that like with
the explosion from the staff if all that
does is shatter
that feels like an issue I feel like At
first like if shattered or if Frozen
Should shatter if not frozen should
freeze like it should do both okay but
like you know if you shoot it from a
projectile you go up and there's some
still more guys coming if you shatter
some of them but the rest of them that
say maybe we're marching towards you
those should be frozen if it doesn't
work that way and the other one's just
like some damage and the freeze isn't
there too I feel like it doesn't
function how it would should in my head
I guess so I'm hoping that's how that
works now the fact that and we'll kind
of get through this too the melee is
basically the same as what your super
knows so the melee is the same like the
projectile for freezing that looks like
a smaller version that's what they do
when they freeze the hunter in PvP and
the little footage we have right and
then that's the one where it's like it's
a melee Frozen Hunter and then bam
sniper shop pop some shatters them so
there are other ways to shatter but yeah
the primer detonator
seems kind of like the way they're gonna
go maybe it's like set them up knock
them out I just don't know how required
the Frozen before shattering is gonna be
especially for the super for the Warlock
overall I think it's pretty cool just
like if you and especially if you just
like projectile projectile projectile
just like freeze half a room or
something bro and then especially just
the Titan starts running through just
slide slides and you can just like clear
half a room like that's got potential
one thing that I I'm sorry getting my if
I let you go I got something after you
um so like my other quote my other
question is is like who especially if
like PVP or you know like PVE because it
generates orbs uh because it is a super
like who gets credit for the kill
[Laughter]
yo that sounded so kd-ish
[Applause]
Detonator type style
you could set him up but if you don't
finish them you only did half the work
you got to be the one that loads them
but what if you can't finish them
because you failed at your job
what about the
bathroom
the shatter and take the kill as the
king of assists by the way I can tell
you I can throw grenades out all day and
hurt people but if I don't get that last
Bulletin
that's all them and not me believe me
I'm the king of assists all the KDA that
looks higher than it should because I
tagged a bunch of people but haven't
killed anybody in the entire match
for being messy at the KD report or
stasis he like that's nice but who's
getting
that's what I'm wondering
salute the youth for being busy I love
it your PVP Bessie is lit man I got I
gotta respect that I gotta respect that
yo
it's a good question it's a good
question
gets them okay they have the footage the
Titan comes down does the slam and
freezes the Warlock comes in and does
the shatter the Warlock just got all
those kills I have to assume I would
assume too that's the way I would that's
the way I would read the situation
you're gonna get a lot of assists yeah
but I don't think you got those kills
VA cheats
my assist number is probably insanely
High I'm sure I punched too much and I
assist too much I just can't kill
anything so what I was gonna say before
but if I had the most hilarious line oh
was that one thing as we cool as far as
the freezing melee is one thing I loved
about when they redid top tree Dawn
blade right is we finally had a
projectile that solar uh projectile
right I I love Celestial five something
cool about having a projectile melee so
to have this again giving y'all some
exotic game man let's get them claws of
amankara out let's Dustin wolf man get
two of those bad boys you know what I'm
saying stop freezing things up man
what's what's the Exotic that restores
Health on melee kill oh that's my baby
that's what I was looking for that's my
almost becoming my number one you
talking about it all what is it no no no
uh exotic
carnstein arm millets yeah that's it
whoa whoa those have now skyrocketed
to almost my number one as far as
hardcore PVE content because that slap
will keep you alive you get that
continuous energy going up to keep you
you know who uses it too I gotta shout
them out um shout out to I think it was
Aries I was watching Aries one time he
doesn't do it
but I thought it was somebody was
watching maybe it wasn't Arizona
you're correct it was somebody else I
was watching that was doing solo
prophecy and they had corn scenes on I'm
like you know what I gotta use them more
they're so effective
so effective they are one of my one of
my Titan solo Flawless runs was ruined
by a not quite punch so if that little
heel would have been in there believe me
yeah but my Titan was I did that on the
wrong subclass but I finished so anyway
patient and persistent so warlock shade
binder now
I wanted to ask you guys this
um we'll get to the Titan here in just a
minute because that's more me this is
you guys
the way they have these subclasses set
up
this is kind of their they've mentioned
as an experiment with the way they want
to do subclasses this like when we got
the Warlock articles the first time we
got to see aspects and we also got to
see fragments now the aspect
specifically is one of those things that
you equip and that's what allows your
Rift to freeze without that it won't be
doing that so we know that's how that
functionality gets there we also have
the fragments which are going to say
defeating Frozen targets with weapons
grants you super energy
so you have this way to like customize
your build which seems fairly cool
but you have one super now if this is an
experiment and we'll dig into the
aspects and fragments here in a little
bit I wanted to ask you guys take your
current subclasses Arc solar and void
yeah if their experiment is to
consolidate those down to one super not
three
what do you what do you want left for
Arc solar and void
what remains so like solar you got top
and bottom tree
what are you keeping that's a good
question yeah you can only keep one oh I
got my ideas
he want me to jump off so
like which one would I keep yeah you can
only keep one super per subclass so like
you can only keep one solar super
so that's that that's so tough because
like I love top tree for like you know
like solar especially is unique for each
three yeah
Golden Gun three six and then also blade
barrage
yeah for for solar on warlock uh top
tree for you know just just skirting all
over the place
yeah uh middle tree for uh you just
if you ain't got nothing else to run I'd
always just run middle tree and then
I've actually been recently using bottom
trees because for like how because like
as someone that always runs top tree for
PVP and then middle tree for PVE I've
been experimenting with a bottom tree
because like even though top tree uh
your your Don blade does track a little
bit a little bit
unmatched and you keep getting it back a
little bit when you yes yes and then
like the solar explosions and stuff
which can then chain into like other
kills such a good subclass I really
don't know if I could choose I think
that like if I was a PVP person top tree
if I was a PVE person I still want to
say topcha because top tree is so much
that was so fun yeah it is you gotta be
picking between my kids
okay so next up is what no hold on I
want to see Cognito solar okay okay man
oh this is evil um I get to do it to my
types if I gotta say super
as much as I love doing blade I think I
gotta say well because well is just
functionality it's just functionality
and it's the only out of the three it's
the only support one so if I'm gonna
sacrifice the offensive supers I'd
sacrifice Dawn blade to keep well as far
as I need my Celestial fight that coming
with me so that's from the melee
um riffs are all pretty much the same
and the movement yeah I need the I need
my bird movement you know that little
free Twilight Garrison we got going on
you know what I'm saying like I love
that so that's probably it as far as the
um was it the man the grenade the
grenades are the same so I know it's
just like just the super just that side
of the tree oh it's the super yeah the
rest is all going to function the same
way because you get to pick your yeah
you get to pick your grenade you get to
picture class ability yeah super said if
I I would say we gotta keep for for
balance we'd have to keep well because
the other two when we get to them
stormcaller offensive you know whatever
which one you want to keep and then um
you know Nova bomb is Nova bomb baby and
I can't say it is yeah you know so yeah
I would I I hate that I love Dawn blade
don't get me wrong especially bottom
tree Dawn blade especially you know I
mean so yeah that's that's where I'm
going right now that's that's a tough
one that's a tough one for Arc and void
since he just went through his really
fast
all right I already know
um avoid the devour yeah I love devour
it like that's so easy like yeah I've
been experimenting with top tree because
I believed valor's bottom tree right
yeah okay I'm just making sure uh top
tree I was actually you know experienced
uh experimenting around looking for you
know some new bills to talk about and
whatnot and uh I I think it was a void
day for Solstice and keep in mind I only
got one character done for Solstice and
I I refuse to do the other ones I just
couldn't do it anymore but uh during one
of those days I was using bottom tree
and I was like okay slap on graviton
Lance I finally got the Catalyst fully
up right explosions you know if if I
punch something with a melee explosions
my Nova bomb you know hits and then it
explodes out and just like seeks things
and whatnot and I was like I love top
tree middle tree I absolutely cannot use
ever I don't I do not like middle tree
middle tree the only time that I liked
it was whenever
um that grenade in that exotic uh yeah
believe me I hated that damn thing
handheld Supernova I hated it but here's
the thing stuff I hate like I also love
using so like yeah that's nice so I like
PVP man I like I would just run around
throw that but like I wouldn't mind
because the super was so bad like like
the super didn't make sense anytime I
would pop super uh it was just a running
game until they eventually would just
outrun me and my secrets
100 it'd be bottom tree devour yeah I
mean it's hard to fight [__] you're
making all the valid points I mean I
will say this though I do prefer even
though it's gonna be bottom Tree by
Landslide I do prefer the the slova ball
oh
that even though it's slow you could not
be active
and those four little projectiles jump
out and start seeking you yeah I love
that you know and then another thing
that's underrated about top tree is most
people don't charge up the grenade yeah
you can make your axions crazy more
powerful and then make them split into
threes you know I mean I love throwing
that so I am going to I actually use top
tree a lot for PVP actually but
uh it listen bro devour like it's just
so hard to be so hard to beat then you
get the constant devour cycle if you
kill someone with the grenade then the
file kicks in if you guys don't want to
melee the bug now they added but they
recently added when you kill someone to
Super devour you know saying and it
leaves the um they actually buffed the
uh what is it the little bubble that is
remains after the Nova on bottom tree
Sue Vortex Vortex so yeah it's just so
powerful and then like like I said we
both love cornsteins you throw
Constantine you're tanking stuff now now
here's the thing I'm not gonna run so
like my build with devour is and it like
the stars have to align the stars have
to align for this to work um and they
are currently aligned right now with the
seasonal artifact they want some armor
piercing rounds on a void weapon with
nazaraxin bottom tree and then throw on
breach resonator and you're 100 getting
every like supers are back like within
like a minute you have constant grenade
beads melees it's disgusting it's got
one of the builds that I've talked about
before and beautiful uh and then on top
of that because you're running void now
you can also throw on oppressive
Darkness oh don't press the darkness and
then let's just get real crazy right
let's just void out every from you know
if you have a if you have a kinetic with
osmosis and that becomes void that
whatever your middle and you void out
and you got that's a record and you just
getting ability devour is nasty devour
is nasty with that with Guillotine we
will yeah right now hold on that with
Guillotine
um and what's the what's the Lucent
Blade the new joint the um bro with the
key that kick in you yeah I could solo
stuff like it's really powerful so yeah
I would I would have to have to give it
up to you on that now one last thing
before we move on I I know I know I know
middle trees getting killed but I used
to like little tree from PvP like it was
obnoxious yeah
they run away but if you you could
literally I could both people to walls I
was doing stuff that I was like they
gonna nerfed them maybe even when that
oh yeah they did out of the ground sadly
we did last word and when that that
class debuted I'm like when people get a
hold of this they are going to Nerf this
internet it is so ridiculous and they're
stupid overhead which he loves that's
his favorite controversial handheld
Supernova cannot stand that crap in PvP
it was bad but that's all I got for
which color we got oh we got Arc oh Lord
that's tough stuff
lightning fingers all right light new
fingers is the win most likely but I
ain't gonna lie to you My Little Dragon
Ball Z joint man powerful for solo
cotton man I hate it in PvP but in PVE
like that's my Gambit build I'll use
that in um geomags and I'll rip through
stuff but I think ultimately Palpatine
does win the question I gotta ask my
father this is a tough one
do you take Ark Buddies
over do you take Arc buddies and and
what's the Thunder crash whatever the
one when you just do it and explore
whoever's in the radius or do you take
the teleporting of top tree
with the whole The Arc web grenades that
chain and like that that's my only
it's tough for me you know what I'm
saying so where you at so I don't
remember if it was uh a exotic or if it
was a um a subclass like selection in D1
that whenever uh stormtrance came out uh
I think it was a subclass selection
where you would always get landfall
that's what you were thinking uh
landfall I can't remember which one it
was but landfall with and correct me if
I'm wrong uh Arc buddies is on the
landfall one right yeah
bottom tree I don't know what it is like
I just I can't get away from it I I I I
love landfalls so much and plus the
whole if you're I believe if it's your
um melee and your super or no your melee
and your grenade are filled when you pop
it then it extends its duration that's
top three Transcendence yeah wait that's
top tree yeah it's tough bro it's two
there's there's two great perks for each
one to separate yeah it is it is it is
now I don't use middle tree I'm mags
I have never been a middle tree guy so
you I would say I agree with you shout
out to um new rad God bless you you
could use Bittle tree and PVP I can God
bless the reason why I would say give it
a try with a high intellect build is not
only are you like it is Extreme DPS
against bosses with geomet and then the
other thing is people sleep on ionic
traces so what it is it almost acts like
a mini
um what you call it a top crown of
Tempest because what will happen is you
keep getting kills and those little
traces come back and they're giving you
super energy melee energy grenade like
it's a con it's a little flow it it's
it's powerful man like trust me it's
very underrated I know the other two if
you put a gun in my head are better if
you what I feel so what I've had a lot
of Effectiveness with it man gotta give
it a shot give it a shot one time yeah I
think it was this most recent GM uh one
of our uh teammates actually ran uh
chaos region we were putting in some
good damage I think we actually ended up
beating it with with his chaos reach but
wow I've just never I don't know it's
it's like Arc is my most underused uh
like I I don't use it hardly so so the
arca's live what was what was it is it
void for you first and then so
solar void and then our Argus dead last
I rarely ever use it for PVE or PVP
because like I feel like top tree is
more dominant
um or I feel like top tree if you can
Master the movement which I know I
haven't but I've just seen someone with
a Mastery of top tree and like how fast
they can move and how like evasive they
are
um top tree I believe is like 100 the
best PVP class for a warlock now I've
seen some people uh that are nasty on on
on art or on uh storm transfer PVP but
it's just something about someone with a
top tree that has Mastery over the
movement uh that I feel like that's just
King for when it comes to warlock
subclasses for PVP and then for PVE it's
like well you have well as well and you
have well or or or you can run like
oppressive Darkness with um with like a
void subclass I I feel you on that Arc
is just one of those things that I just
kind I look over I just never use it
listen man yeah I I you're making valid
points nothing you said is incorrect
like I said I think I I do use ARC a
little bit more I think for me it's
tough you're right it's tough because
both yeah
I'm gonna say something controversial
I would say I use solar less than most
someone is probably my least use not
that it's that good because everything
you said with the movement and
everything you said with the well but
it's something about being very
offensive I like about I mean well void
is number one for me as far as
functional I feel you can you could just
survive everything and void I actually
use for PVP as well so I would say Arc
is my middle I'm gonna go Arc of my
middle that's so don't get me wrong but
it's all close solar is great you know
what I'm saying it's your helpful rate
in the your helpful warlock in those
raids running those Wells all the time
no you're not I I know I use it when I
have to though yeah whatever but I don't
I don't like to just be that sole use
but it's super effective so I mean I
don't know if that's what they're gonna
do is actually slowly roll that out you
know I was literally talking to one of
my streams about this stuff too and I
was saying potentially if we get stasis
this season the experiment of how they
rolled out the subclass they kind of
narrowed it down to one we'll see if
aspects change stuff up with the super
see how fun those are to use I was
wondering over the course of this next
season if they want to be like okay
we're gonna spend each season on a
subclass and be like season 13 is Arc
season 14. season 15. I want to see if
you think that's how they could you know
make that shift over the course of this
year
I think so I think I think this is the
ultimate evolution of where things are
going I think they've they've
continually repeated Luke Smith has
continually repeated you know um we we
like they they Don the MMO name finally
right remember before they would Dodge
that they they want to get back to this
awkward stuff I think that you know
stasis represents the direction they
want to go Woodstock stopper classes
which is a little better a little better
some D1 nuances but an evolution of it
and making it better and I like I love
the pick and choose I love that because
we all have to admit the way it is with
D2 right now you're stuck that whole
thing and it's something we just we we
right now we're like killing ourselves
cringing if we had to pick based on your
great question what if your two aspects
were going to be like hey if I'm gonna
run the arc subclass I've got Arc buddy
and I've got blink with my super yeah
bro like I mean and you could put and
you choose to put those things to join
and that's what I miss about D1 that
that having that customization of your
subclass is so powerful that's what I
missed and this is D1 stuff why I love
it you know I'm saying it it becomes
personal becomes your warlock build yeah
your you know what I'm saying like I
mean there will be an optimal but yeah
you can still I'll enjoy watching people
like the kme kicks like the drewskis who
like dig into the tiny little nuances of
this one little build and make their
little nugget of their own build that
nobody else thinks about and they're
like I'm just the counter to you and it
took a long time for them to make it but
those are going to be the fun ones to
see all the variety yeah my last Point
hey shout out it's not an MMO yet I
agree but this is the direction they
want to go and I'm all about promoting
that that that's what I'm saying like
they took away that's why I was so angry
with D2 they took away my choice they
they told me I have to do this with this
Cloud I'm like since when why are we
doing this like why can't I pick and
choose I remember yeah solar Viking
funeral in there this and picking the
type of Nova bomb I wanted and like
that's what I'm missing what you think
you think this is the the evolution of
this thing
yeah I'm gonna have to go ahead and say
that uh I I mean I I don't see anything
like where I could potentially counter
argue the like that it should stay the
same and instead or it like it it's just
it should say how it is now uh I do like
the fact that we're gonna be able to
kind of pick and choose so it's like
okay I want to run ARC today but I don't
have to run like like I'm not bound to
the constraints of them of of like
what's on middle tree or what's on top
tree or what's on bottom tree I I can
kind of like pick and choose from within
the arc subclass and I think builds are
going to be really fun and uh
yeah I I I'm really looking forward to
it
[Music]
big time yeah
I think so I mean that's my guess I'm
the one you said it in the first place
so yeah uh but I mean I like the idea of
what potentially the aspects in the
fragments bring because the aspects
depending on how many you have how much
customization they get to them I mean
maybe you have a slova bomb versus a
Nova bomb
and then you also look into some of the
aspects themselves actually have more
fragment slots than it looks like others
do so maybe
an aspect that changes your super to be
something more substantial it has less
fragment slots but an aspect that you
know makes your riff freeze people gives
you more fragments for a little more
customization that way so that because
they have the number of like fragment
slots and then you see the choices down
there I'm like
and they're not all the same they're
like not all aspects are created it
created equal so I'm kind of wondering
I'm sorry no no and then like the
fragments and one other person I want to
ask you guys too was wondering they're
like oh I don't want to grind for these
things I'm like I don't in my mind to
picture these as being insanely hard to
acquire more just like giving you the
options of custom I was wondering how
you guys think you're going to acquire
the aspects and the fragments for these
subclasses is it going to be a quest
line or is it just going to be random
drops till you get them
because I don't picture them have having
there's not going to be like or they're
not going to be random world like hey I
got a fragment that's got like minus
strength and I'm like cool what that is
supposed to minus recovery from my
warlock I think the fragments and the
aspects are going to be like certain
sets and then you build from there would
be my guess but I wonder how you guys
think we'll acquire those
I think man
so I would say I
I don't know because like I feel like
fragments fragments are reminding me a
lot of of um like mods and stuff and I
remember we used to get mods via like
like like
[Music]
weapon drops I believe is is kind of
like what I'm drawn from it's it's one
of those things where I I think it's
gonna be tied to something like it's not
just you're just gonna go out in the
world and open a chest and find a
fragment you know like I feel like it's
going to be tied to something maybe like
armor or like you'll dismantle it and
you'll throw it but I don't see how it
would work with armor because armor
doesn't go on fragments where like mods
of course would go on weapons and you
could dismantle them and put them on a
certain weapon you wanted uh I I don't
see I mean I remember fragments kind of
remind me of like seeds of light just
not to that like extreme extent where a
seat of light was okay you get an
entirely new subclass tree where
fragments are more of like kind of like
little modifications and stuff
um
I I could see it being bound as like
kind of like uh it could be in like
nightfalls and stuff like that where
because I I know like Master night falls
or Grand Master one of the two oh
nightfalls in general at a high chance
for um you know uh in was it enhanced
mods
um so I I think that they'll be kind of
like you know you can get them here you
can get them there but if you want to
like like a really high chance a chance
it's going to be tied to kind of like
sort of like an in-game type thing
I mean um they've got a lot of
possibilities with this to your previous
Point E I think it's almost
um with the fragment thing I just wanted
to double down like I think they're
almost gonna go with how they I think
they kind of gave us a preview of how
they did with the armor slots right
where it's like okay you're not like
intellect costs five right and this
costs you know whatever so I think it's
gonna be cost so that you can't just get
too crazy with everything it's going to
be limits because some abilities they
know are going to be powerful and then
as you can see in a lot of these
pictures that I'm seeing right now I'm
seeing like Whisper of bonds okay if you
put that on defeats Frozen uh targets
with weapons Grant you super energy it's
pretty powerful right so but what
they're doing is okay minus 10 intellect
minus 10 discipline the minute you put
that on so there's like checks and
balances with certain things right now
to you too that's so much though they
have to bro it could get crazy
the stats yeah they can be beneficial
but it's just like I it bugs me that
that's how they balance stuff
what do you prefer just take the stats
off of there the stats are not that game
breaking in the first place especially
for I mean yeah you can have good builds
but that's literally the point so let me
choose how I want to play and then still
lose stats it's that just still bugs me
a little bit okay so you feel it's like
counter-intuitive to the customer yeah
it's like hey I want to customize but I
take a penalty to do it
right no I get what you're saying I mean
it don't feel good like I I know I know
where you're going and it's Daddy Bungie
you know how they do it's like you know
I can't say hey I don't like it I know
listen no I'm not saying you I you know
I'm all about this like balance the
stuff in a different balance the stuff
in a different way as opposed to be like
oh you got this like I hope it's like
you gotta dance with it yeah you get to
slap yeah
check we're gonna let you play but just
don't go past this yard like that's
really yeah this is the dog fence
you're absolutely right and I would love
you know what I like when they get crazy
you don't say I like when they get crazy
but I do hate what you're saying
um yeah to modify's point you know it
would be cool to throw these into
um like you said nightfalls and you know
high-end activities to say okay yo if
you wanna there's a higher chance you
know you can get that Jane if you run
this so that Master Nightfall and you
know just get people in these different
activities to get it now you know
obviously it will be some controversy if
they put them even though I love PVP if
they put them in PvP because I could
tell the PVE Community gonna be upset if
they hey they're gonna do that but you
know me I don't mind get you behind and
play these other things
are going to be broken deal with it deal
with it bro there's always something in
this game that's broken like that's not
good oh yeah absolutely but that's what
I got but shade binder overall I'm super
excited this is the type of
customization I want I want to choose
how my warlock is I'm hyped man this is
this is the D1 type stuff I like so I'm
I'm in
or else we gotta eat uh well we got
subclass number two that's mine you guys
talk like for I'm just been sitting back
here like I'll just mute
you guys talk about the warlocks let you
guys have your fun let's get it the sad
thing about the Titan I will tell you
okay let's get it it feels too much like
Arc
how I feel about this one now freezing
stuff you know the [__] but come down
and then punching the shatter but
literally
when you watch the from the b-roll from
the Prescott when you watch the gameplay
come down and oh shatter and then oh
punch so like you like okay Landon Arc
and then you punch it feels
I'm not saying they didn't do different
animations because the colors and the
effects are going to look the same but
like the movement still feels very free
yeah there you go haul
it hail and Theresa I'm trying to make
sure I read it right
yeah I'm like that's it's freezy Arc
it's you know it's not gonna have
thunder crash to it you're not gonna be
able to go quite that far but
it does feel like you know Striker do
you feel you feel you feel cheap and sir
do you feel do you feel dare I say
it was a little lazy
yeah like let's let's talk about it I
mean for me it feels a little now the
melee has more potential it's got the
slowing upon impact it's got knock back
on your enemy and you kind of plow
through what you're going for so the
melee shiver strike
seems like it has potential to actually
do some cool stuff
um as for ground control I mean the ice
quick kind of looks cool for the
freezing I mean it is all about the you
know Prime Detonator freezing shatter so
you're gonna literally land Shadow
everything in front of you turn around
and punch it which seems kind of cool in
theory but I was like it doesn't have a
different feel like you guys now granted
if you look at the Warlock that's a Nova
bomb or that's a Nova warp explosion the
explosion uh and then you have your
projectile which is any projectile so
again it's like I guess we're seeing
here's where like he knows we were
joking I think last time we were like
hey maybe in witch Queen we get a
Darkness subclass from that one and
maybe in lightfall we have three and
three by the time we're all done with
these next three years
these don't feel as different as I would
like them to to get me excited about
like three more like to set everything
apart because if it's hey it's a noble
War but it's got ice on it hey it's a
striker but it's got ice on it and that
what's the what's the hunter it's a
blade barrage with a pickaxes
and it's a throwing knife but it's a
bouncy ninja star so I mean and I'm not
trying to like bash monkeys work sorry
guys
but it is one of those we've got we
gotta keep it real at least we're like
it's one of those to where it feels to
me like these are skins of supers they
don't stand out to be on their own like
Nova bomb chaos reach blade barrage Don
blade so like you know you got Thunder
crash what but like they are so proud so
yeah right now so like they're all cool
these feel like skins of supers with ice
comes out because that's right that's
just what I read so yeah see jigsaw is
saying like yeah pickaxe Play Brush so
it's like yeah
so it was like not to be Debbie Downer
in here because apparently you guys
like 20 minutes to come in here and just
shut down the podcast
this is stuff Cognito says it gets
killed so I'm glad you said it so I
would love not that you got killed by
you I'm just saying something yeah I
don't want to be Debbie down either but
I felt that in my heart too but I was
like I'm gonna keep this in and I will
see what people say
to Spade I will I don't know how to do
that
to be honest with you like I'm I'm
completely I kind of know it's the same
thing like I mean of course it wasn't as
apparent with the Warlock and the hunter
as it was with a Titan like I remember
like as soon as we saw that first little
clip of that Titan literally someone in
my chat goes oh nice Thunder crash is
back but it's icy and I'm like yeah yeah
pretty yeah that's pretty much what it
is but like when you start looking at
the other subclasses it's like oh like
that really is just an icy blade brush
or oh that really is just a Nova War
pitch just now you're holding a staff
and it's ice
um to be honest I'm I don't don't get me
wrong I'm looking forward to stasis but
what I'm more looking forward to is the
is the further uh what we were just
talking about where you can kind of pick
and choose from each tree like that's
exactly honestly like that's what I'm
looking forward to the most I'm with my
fight that's the that's what's saving me
from not going in right yeah because I
was like everything he is saying I felt
but I was like if I say that I'm gonna
get killed no I was like they're gonna
be like he's a hater that's why we share
a podcast if you don't I will vice versa
I just want to see what people say and
then once he said it it's literally the
only thing that is what you just said my
Father which I was like you know what
but I will live with it because they
giving me customization on abilities and
how I want to do things so in that
regard okay I'm Gonna Let You rock with
your little icy skin you know what I'm
saying or certain things and then you
know whatever but I'm with y'all I'm
with both of y'all completely agree with
you I was like and then Halen Theresa
says it means it does might be hard to
come up with like creative supers like
so you sit there and we joked about hey
which Queen's gonna introduce another
subclass and then or in elements because
everything about the witch Queen and
Sabbath is always this green stuff the
only element we don't have yet is green
for sure so at some point that thing
feels like it could potentially come
with her coming back we get some like
Hive powers
again if it's like another reskin it
kind of hurts so it's like it they have
some cool stuff out there I just hope
this is like this is maybe what they're
stuck with this is maybe what we get
yeah it's like and then we sit here and
like wonder what Exotics are gonna come
from this like yeah she was a Titan I'm
gonna ask you like as a Titan with what
you're seeing you know I'm saying seeing
tectonic Harvest here I'm seeing Whisper
of during slow slow from your abilities
last longer like any are you thinking of
any bills exotic wise as a Titan that
maybe excites you with with stasis that
you can come up with I mean from what I
can see the whisper of Durant it says
slow from your abilities last longer
yeah
the only slow we have is from the melee
punch because that's the melee punch on
impact slows those around you so they
will slow it longer and that does give
you tender strength as a plus because
that's a melee ability so that kind of
does kind of go hand in hand as for
builds
I mean
I haven't even honestly thought that
deep about have been playing a lot of
Avengers to be completely honest yeah
the Avengers has been fun I mean so
there's a lot of the Exotics for the
Titan that are I mean acting more based
on weapons you got
um you know Dune Marchers with shoulder
charge if it's a shoulder charge type
could be not doing Marchers um Mark 44
standard sides that one okay so that one
if shiver strike because they somewhere
I heard somewhere somebody I think it
might have been missed five thousand
Watts set it on DCP they're like the
shiver strike is
someone said it like the most powerful
melee they built because it does have
the knockback it has the slowing effect
it kind of plows their enemies to your
Target and I was like well you could buy
that with Mark 44 standard side so you
get that back more frequently that's got
potential yes sir synthesps would
definitely be one Chad says heart of
inmost light
yeah so heart of inmost light is going
to be
um the healing pulse when the barricade
is active right
maybe and then again this is like how
creative do they get does your well
freeze do I get an aspect that my wall
shoots out of freezing wave in front of
it where it's like class abilities
freeze is there a hunter one where as
you dodge kind of like the bombardiers
there's a freezing effect around like is
this
feedback fence that might have been
another one um
actually just got one of those
so like all of those I'm wondering like
is it just gonna be hey when you're
doing like here's this little blast of
Frozen stuff that happens with your
class ability I'm curious to see how
deep they go on these things because
they have decent ideas but they don't
always flesh everything out as much as I
hope in the beginning so if we have like
three or four of each thing it's gonna
be like yeah okay there's two good ones
two bad ones we're good and there's not
as much customization
if there are like 10 different ones and
they really think I'm through and you
get some cool customization and they
actually get to a little you know
powerful aspects to them then I could
get excited but until I actually think
about it like how most 814 can't do
anything mask of The Quiet One that's
just all the time that one's okay uh I'm
literally look through them solar
Rampart solar damage
one-eyed mask I mean there's only so
many insurmountable skull Fort is Arc
melee abilities there's a lot that are
specific to like certain classes for the
Titan
but I'm not actually seeing a whole
bunch that are going to be
and and and again not not to hate on D2
again but again this is my problem with
with D2 Exotics or two class or ability
specific where that it's tied to you
have to use it with oh there's so many
Exotics in D2 that yeah there's so many
that need love and don't even get me
started that our class item doesn't even
have like
my class item doesn't have stats on it
that give a damn like you get three
class items for you're done for a year
like there's they're very I feel Exotics
in D2 sometimes are way too safe yeah
way too safe I mean that's when you're
saying like Daddy Bungie doesn't want
stuff to be broken but then there's 75
of the Exotics that a lot of people
don't touch unless you're like hey let
me pull this one thing out for this one
little bit this is one thing that works
for like this one nugget of place that's
my problem yeah one argument because you
like let me give an example
uh we'll start to talk more like with my
file for a second
you know what's the coolest looking
exactly they just debuted that what is
it Prometheus spur
that one that when you're in Blade yeah
when you're in Dawn blade and you kill
someone to Rift appears I'm like
what yeah
everywhere else but where I am where I
am I'm just gonna kill Rand I'm like
okay you gotta build oh baby my if I
gotta build I don't know about yeah
Shadow keep right that you got or at the
end of like
I think with Shadow keep never touched
it never touched the Exotic I saw one
review on it and I was like uh I think
it was mtash's review yeah he was like
why would you use this and I was like
all right I bet I'm not using it that's
my problem with D2 it's so oh it it
frustrates me with with and the Exotic
looks so cool yes it does it does and
it's just like why would it be locked to
this very specific obscure activity you
know what I'm saying like even like a
class ability like riffs but hold on
there's all these guys across the map
and I just killed them all
is it takes them
solo if ever to rework an exotic that is
useless like they clearly have the
there's no way in bungee they don't have
a board with the statistic usage of each
exotic right there's there's got to be
like five or six like a bar graph like
this tall five or six on the top that
are like way out here and then the rest
are like point one percent yeah exactly
I'm like bro this sucks and we know e
you know how we feel about exotic armor
specifically it should be exotic and
half of them suck yeah and it's just
like they need they need to be a rework
team right for armor Armor gets no love
okay here's the issue is like they don't
even need a rework team they need to
make them interesting when they come out
in the first place yeah like like who
said finish she said you know what don't
blink needs
time
I want to be in that pitch where like
this person created this person approved
it somebody above was like cool let's
put that in there and somebody's gonna
spend time to build an art asset which
looks amazing nobody uses then nobody
uses that that
budget I love y'all but it's just like
yeah I was like I I wonder sometimes
sometimes especially this season's
exotic or this year a lot of this year's
Exotics have been
questionable I like for my Titan oh my I
can't remember one of the ones where
what's the one if I do a finisher punch
I get an explosion around it
uh Satan's ramparts that's it yes yes no
okay now Titans ramparts you can shoot
through your towering barricade that's
not bad that's not bad I like that I
like it but the one where it's like if
you punch or do a finisher a melee
ability kill or a finisher you get an
explosion and the bigger thing you punch
the bigger the explosion you're telling
me you want me to go punch a boss you're
out of your ever loving mind stop
mechanic
like life at your exotic armor whoever's
on the exotic armor team we gotta have a
conversation yeah like okay so we get it
we get Beyond light we get three more
Exotics and we're sitting here like I
don't know how many Exotics we're gonna
get again expansion hopefully get more
than three but how many did he get with
Shadow keep they introduced them
throughout the seasons but I can't
hardly tell you many of them that came
out all year long weapons have been
better you know shout out to Effigy
shout out to wither [__] I I did laugh
don't those were better I I really don't
know but exotic armor bungee we need to
have an intervention we have to sit down
and we we have a problem and we and if
you're not gonna make new ones then we
need to rework old ones that are not
getting any use you know what I'm saying
well I mean you have the same line
alchemy that truly like changed its
functionality that was cool but let's be
honesty
it was that much it ain't gonna use that
much but we know damn what I was getting
changed because the original perk allow
allowed you to put the rift down I'm
saying to see people and they knew
trials was coming so that was that was
out of necessity that so trials would be
broken that's the real reason why that
was doing it was break it up but
continue
no let's just yeah apparently this is an
exotic rant but I mean we've talked
about this before it was like I mean
when we started our podcast in the
middle of curse of Osiris still don't
know how we did it we're at episode 119
so thank God it made it but yes we're at
a point there and I I cannot remember
how many times I screamed into the
microphone not literally but I was just
like exotic should be exotic and right
now again it was that time where not a
lot of like the weapons weren't feeling
it how many people pick a gnawing hunger
and the only Exotics you typically use
are heavies yeah yeah one either because
you have to because of barrier mods or
the mods that you have to use in the
first two slots and then you're looking
at so there's so many weapons that you
don't get use out of that we've all
acquired in this weird thing and we need
to put that vote for you which is
um the Exotic being able to use the the
thing the anti-barrier and all that
stuff so we keep how fun would it be to
use Rat King you know with an overload
thing on it right like allow the the
slot for the the champion stuff to be on
Exotics so then those old Exotics get
functional how fun it would be to use a
lot of these Exotics any weapons should
just have an overload a barrier and the
third one Unstoppable every weapon
should be able to use those so you have
a choice of what your loadout's gonna be
of how you're gonna attack it not say
you get to play with these five weapons
this season yeah oh yeah
I think it's Bungie's way of pretty much
just trying to like
um like pretty much trying to force
people not to use the same weapons
forever every season in hopes of then
they won't get as much backlash of oh
well it's I just use the same guns all
year like there's there's no point for
me to go out and grind these different
guns where I I think Bungie thought
maybe it like it would actually do
something but at the end about at the
end of the day it's like okay well I
have a Scout rifle and I use that just
for that one activity if you're gonna
make any new Scout Raffles buff them for
the love of God Beyond light snipers
yeah like snipers I mean they haven't
even thrown the mods on specials like
what if you could like a
I'm blinking on these things uh overload
Fusion rifle done they're marching at
you shut them down just
hit him with like a few bolts and they
stop in place
bro snipers they love shout out to um
I've been using actually been using a
lot because I got the Catalyst final it
was Borealis and I'm like man Borealis
is really effective too bad it doesn't
hit hard the snipers are just so trash
that I'm just like damn this is really
effective sauce is used by the data
people fall out the Mercury and
everybody else to measure distances that
is all that gun is used for
it's funny like you say right Darcy's
just used for that but RC is 100 now
it's like yeah they did get it busted
the damage they gave it like 4X but it's
are you gonna use that over
your other heavy slots like Darcy if it
was a special then you could use
delirium and again some of that stuff
just there's so much we don't know about
Beyond light but there's so many things
that I feel like we want that we're not
gonna get nearly enough to make like the
shift we're like that's why some of us
did want a D3 is because bless you
um
ad3 is because you do get this like
complete new slow of Exotics you get the
new feeling of a whole lot of things you
get and and this is like
still pushing it forward and that was
why I was like when I talked about sun
setting Exotics like there's when it at
least when it comes to armor right now
they could Sunset 75 of the Exotics and
you wouldn't bat an eye and I know it
yeah
still though the problem remains even
with subsetting is that they've got to
be ballsy enough to make these things
really effective especially on that's
why I don't even have confidence with
with that because it's like
with the new stuff that they're adding
let's just say they did Sunset let's say
stuff was like again I I hate to pick on
you Prometheus fur but I I have to do it
it's like when they create things like
that yeah I'm just like I don't have
confidence it's armor weapon wise yes
they always do something fun they always
do something creative whoever's on the
weapon team but I don't know if they
understaffed on the harmony I don't know
if that was vicarious Visions I don't
know if that was how whoever's on the
armored team we gotta have a talk what
are y'all doing what are y'all doing for
and I'm never a disrespectful person but
it's been too many seasons now we've
been talking about this since we start
when we when last word was Flashpoint
we've been talking about this ain't
something like we me and E have been
fighting the good fight for exotic armor
and armor in general you know what I'm
saying and it's just like it's just so
behind it's like it's not a priority and
that's the frustration because this game
could be so much more and it's just the
resources either limited or being put
towards other digs
they still make it a weapon focused
shooter yes and the armor is
very much been a second that armor 2.0
is a step in the right direction but 3.0
still needs to happen and sadly not
happening for a year because we know
Solstice of Heroes Armor is going to
last for years so there's not going to
be any major changes to armor and as
soon as I heard that news that I like my
heart dropped I love I know I felt it I
felt it
hey
we got we got more time we need more
times needed unfortunately you know it
just sucks but you know at the end of
the day we we will say this I know this
is we've been I've been bashing a little
bit but we do understand you know them I
had no b2b2 I'm not going to throw you
on the bus we'll die on that sword
together but um you know at the end of
the day we understand you know low
resources you know you're on your own
you got to pick and choose your battles
but we have to be balanced with the
things that need attention you know and
right now anti-cheat
armor these are things that if you don't
start fixing people are going to stop
playing you know especially those
aspects of the game you know I mean and
we don't want that we want this game to
flourish we want this thing to live and
we'll go I'm gonna continue to rent
and I'm gonna run down on something they
talk about an MMORPG
five of your character slots
more than the half of them like the
majority of your character slots feel
kind of neglected like stats don't have
as much effect you're talking about cool
down times Mobility doesn't even make
you run faster like if they want to
embrace the RPG that's gotta matter too
so like that's the whole armor side of
your characters half of it and that's
what like you think about an RPG you
have usually maybe like one or two
weapon slots and it's all about the
armor the artifacts like the Helms so
many pieces to an RPG and if they want
to embrace it there's a lot that goes
into that that they're not doing
dedicated servers yeah that's all
vaged is in his bag right now don't let
me started with that [__] excuse me in
the back like don't get me started with
dedicated like we
what are your thoughts about like all
this stuff like where are you at in the
state of Destiny like I know you do a
lot of Sherpas and things like that but
just for
looking forward like are you I know
we're excited about Beyond light for
like the story and stuff like that but
where are you on just like some of this
like you know when you get into the the
grind the builds and things like that
where you at
um well to be honest like what you all
were saying about how you know of course
I wish there was dedicated servers and
of course I wish there was an anti-g and
of course I'm excited for Beyond light
but yeah at this point I'm kind of like
I'm I'm excited but you know I'm not
like if you took like if you took my
current energy uh or how you know I am
you know kind of uh feeling about Beyond
light and then you know compared it to
you know how I was feeling about
something like the taken king or you
know like one of those other bigger
expansions uh that that were coming up
not to say that I'm not excited because
I most definitely am but I'm more just
kind of weary because uh yeah even
though as of right now in Destiny 2
we've had worse times like we've had
year one
um like it's I could definitely say year
two of course was you know a whole lot
uh the drip content was more I think
there uh I think right now we're in kind
of like a pretty even though we have
Solstice we're in a pretty slow point
right now uh one of the things that I
want from Destiny uh is it seems like it
happens every year around this time I
even said it uh as like getting into
being a constant Creator on Destiny 2
you've got to know what you're getting
into you've got to know that Midway
through the year around that uh July
August and September Point
um you're gonna like you're either like
gonna take a Hiatus from creating
content which is kind of like what I'm
doing over on the YouTube side just to
kind of like recharge or you're gonna
try to like pull stuff out of your hat
like like you no longer have like a jar
of like ideas or like notes like at that
point you're you're just all right what
do I got today okay okay we can talk
about this and it's it's like I I want I
want a destiny where I don't have to
even as a player back when you know I
didn't you know do stuff on my own uh
even as just a player that just you know
played as like a hobby like I still
would be like all right yeah uh let's
see Destiny's gonna get slow around you
know July uh other games are gonna start
you know popping off I'm just gonna go
play those other games right now like I
don't want to have to like take a break
from Destiny Midway through the year
because you know I played it a bunch at
at the start like I want more or I just
want Destiny to stop being dead or just
very slow around this time pretty much
because I have a lot of friends uh a lot
of clan mates right now even climates
that uh we are doing that I'm gonna be
doing the world's first raid with that
are currently taking a break from
Destiny and no one's sitting there like
giving him a hard time
um I my biggest one at the end of the
day is for us to not have times like
these where it's it's very slow right uh
that's that's that's pretty much what my
biggest wish for is for Destiny is
around this time just have stuff for us
to do that isn't you know just
re-skinned of the solstice of Heroes
that was the same thing as last year but
I'm not going to get into that we've
covered that too don't worry he ain't
liar he ain't lying no I mean I mean
picture of the Fall which somebody had
like we you have uh
so no um Festival
now the haunted forest isn't being
kicked out yet
what do you guys think Festival is
actually going to change because in
theory Festival is going to be during
Beyond's light Beyond lights like
lifespan right but Mercury was going to
be gone right how do you think Festival
was gonna work do you think they
actually have a different plan for it or
should your expectations be one out of a
hundred that it's like this is true copy
and paste before we get to be on light
because we need to save time
I think it's gonna be different and the
only reason I think that is because I
think that uh Beyond Live course like I
don't think that they just started
working on it post the Activision split
I believe that they were I believe that
the Beyond light was Destiny 3. and I
mean it it I think that makes the most
sense because I mean like over half of
all of our armor and gear is getting
Sunset now whether it's just going to be
complete reskins of the whole the
annoying hunger thing happening again
where it's uh these annoying hunger was
was available uh you know like
uncensored unsetting stuff and yeah and
the reissuing that it's like Beyond
light is going to come out and it's just
gonna be like the same exact weapons and
I'm gonna have to go grind for you know
I I like it that's gonna be annoying but
I I truly honestly believe that with so
many guns getting Sunset that you know
the original plan was for Destiny 2 to
only make it up to year three and then a
death scene three was going to be
released but like I I feel like all that
stuff that they were working on you know
before the Activision split and all that
they didn't just scrap I feel like a lot
of it is gonna make it into Beyond light
and I think Beyond light I am gonna go
ahead out on a like and I hope and I
hope I hope that I'm right I I hope that
I'm right uh and say that Destiny uh two
Beyond light is gonna be bigger then
forsaken uh because I truly believe that
this was going to be an entire like this
was gonna be Destiny three and uh I feel
like that of Festival of the Lost is
gonna be different because it was meant
to be in Beyond light or it was meant to
be in Destiny 3. um so I'm gonna go out
on a limb and say that I think it's
gonna be different I think it's not it's
gonna be a cut copy and paste um and I I
I I hope I'm right I I really do because
I don't know if I could do the infinite
Forest again for the third year in a row
yeah and it's like the revelry and the
festival and the revelry and the
festivals like good
yeah definitely I mean
look I I don't have a lot of confidence
in that of those little events like you
know it is what it is I feel those are
kind of because when is when is Festival
drop is it October October so it's still
it's gonna be a little bit before yeah
right
you know I'm keeping my expectations in
check the the reality is this you know
they needed more time for Beyond life we
are allowing them that now instead of
September to you know to November you
know to me this is just hold the fort
down you know sadly play other things
you know I'm saying I I hate these
moments too it but you know look this
the the reason again back to my D1
versus D2 argument the reason why you
know I'm saying like I get frustrated is
like I said you have these times like
this but I think what's happened now is
people are resigned to it we just become
a customer they can't produce you know
they they just they're they're under
staff they're by themselves we just
resigned to it but the reality is this
is not a good time and I I can count
many times like this where we're like yo
all right we're just gonna have to wait
you know it's just you know they're
broke they broke this month and I'm just
gonna have to wait I've seen this every
day I get my paycheck yeah gotta get the
paycheck you know and then it's gonna be
better and now you know that's why I'm
coming at the D2 lovers like we have way
too many moments where we're not playing
the game we're like yo you know take a
break or you know hey Avengers is out or
play ghosts of Shameless lit I I can I
don't remember those times during D1
they were definitely they were like this
not like this bro like this is I could
count like season of The Drifter black
Armory season of the Unworthy curse of
Osiris like I got mad gaps of two to
three months where we like yo
that's just the reality we got to be
real about it now when it comes back
yeah it's good it's always good that's
what I'm trying to say so look at the
end of the day back to my overall
d i I think Beyond light is going to be
dope my only concern
is I I think it was hot light set it
somebody said is that I just don't want
it to be all about the stasis stuff
and not enough other content yeah
because all just Europa stasis and
everything else is neglected because
we're you know losing seven strikes
we're losing seven strikes uh we've only
got one Gambit mode crucible's being
simplified we're losing planets we've
got a lot it's got to be a massive DLC I
was like I hope right I I think it will
I think it I got confidence in these
fall expansions but again as we learned
you know I'm saying that's that's my I
guess that's my only concern just like
look how much meat is there to it is
there a lot of stuff we don't know you
know and um are they very good about
that but that's going to determine the
success because there is I don't want to
say red flag there are little warning
things like e is saying the amount of
strikes leaving the amount of the daily
activities you know what I'm saying and
look shout out to wall crawler I think
they are holding back I agree with you I
think we're not getting everything
giving it a strip feed give us a little
piece get us excited give us a little
piece get us excited and then we're
gonna get more and get more and then
we'll see how it plays out and then
we'll rate it you know what I'm saying
kind of thing but that's all I got you
know what I'm saying I'm in the end of
the day I'm confident they're gonna do
their thing they've had enough time and
we just gotta say we're gonna see where
that but I am excited about stage I just
want to make sure there is more there's
still you know we got deep Stone [__] we
got all this other stuff I just want to
know what else as we did get closer
that's it
yeah I mean
that's kind of thing agree with that
yeah it's like it's
the the gaps in and of themselves aren't
bad
but when they try and
it's weird because like as you're saying
the gaps in D1 they were there
now there was there was less competition
for the game there's a lot more things
out pulling strings and stuff like that
um but on the other side it's like you
had taken King
you had the April update and then we got
rise of iron we didn't have a lot in
there now granted what did we get the
interim for this year season of unworthy
barely barely counted but story was kind
of cool as they built that there are
the story is like one of the things
keeping me going in this game right now
as the pyramid ships are coming you've
got Aldrin on the possible Horizon
you've got the witch Queen with
sabathune pending about a year later we
don't know what the hell is going to
happen with you know arabis and the
pyramid ship on Europa and the Deep
Stone Crypt there's a lot of potential
there and that's one of those things as
you play through this is like how much
do you dedicate yourself to this
the seasonal model 2 as they keep
bumping up the light level
the I think for one we're six years into
destiny
as we've been playing a looter shooter
from Destiny we've been through many
Evolutions ups and downs and changes and
stuff six years on any franchise is a
long time so I mean some of us are truly
getting to a point to where we're
we gotta take breaks at this point you
almost feel like you have to just to
keep your Santa to be like hey we've got
an extended season September is
literally nothing right you're gonna
have Iron Man a couple weeks off maybe
another iron banner before uh Festival
lost and festival's gonna be in there
maybe with one iron banner and that's
like their fill in time yeah yeah but
even if but even if it wasn't like the
season would have been you'd log in for
the lore every week cool Solstice all
right
like there wasn't as much to this so I'm
like yeah I think to wrap up my overall
rambling thoughts which have been a
whole lot to see this podcast sorry guys
um
good
Beyond light has potential I'm just
weary if it doesn't deliver what it says
about the future of the franchise yeah
no no that that's valid that's fast
that's where I'm at yeah that that's in
the back of my head yep also so I've
been I've been on that page and again I
don't wanna
apologies if I'm coming off a super
Debbie down because I I really am
excited for being online but as you see
we as he said we got to keep it real
like you know we got to see the
execution they gotta fully execute all
the way and then restore that confidence
like they normally always do
um yeah I will say this though like it
will
tell us how things are gonna go
you know moving forward in future
seasons and stuff like that we're going
to learn a lot when when Beyond light
comes out you know I mean and that's it
man I'm excited the last point I'll say
is I think the reason why we're we
afford them as opposed to D1 into your
defense now the reason why I think we
afford them more leniency and and
hanging in is because the thing that D2
does better I will say this is road map
D1 didn't tell you what was going to
happen yeah so you're just frustrated
like yo there's no content what's going
on during this Gap right whereas D2 We
like okay well we know which Queen's
coming we know this is like you know I'm
saying so it gives you it it helps you
to calm yourself okay there's a little
down time right now we know beyond light
coming right then after that yo boom we
know this is like that that's where
they've helped themselves because the
past they were on that you know that
Secret Squirrel stuff and no one's
talking and people are raging like yo
I've got nothing to do and y'all you
know I'm saying what the hell are y'all
doing buddy it used to be beef you know
what I'm saying so at least we got that
transparency and now they give us road
maps and calendars and okay and then
you're like okay this is what I'm gonna
log in here because I see what they're
gonna do this and I said what you got my
phone
all right at the same time of road maps
like don't don't get me wrong I I love
road maps you don't want to know
everything let's go dude like I think
that's the reason I mean I think there's
a lot of reasons why Destiny one didn't
feel as slow as Destiny 2 in some
aspects I think the one of the big
reasons is of course uh you're talking
about a game that was only three years
in in a game now that's going on what
year seven so it's like you know like
Destiny one year one was was was slow
but because it was a new IP it was a new
game it was something fresh uh even
though the content itself wasn't really
there it's just like you know the feel
of the game the the the surrounding
world was all very you know immersive
and uh I feel like that the the reason
why people are getting so bored now
during these slow times is because the
game is seven years old uh you've pretty
much done everything there is to doing
even new stuff that's coming out
you've you've kind of already done it
like your skin Fallen like yeah
five again like I mean that's yep
exactly like and I feel like that's like
the the the biggest reason
um
uh I would like to I
it's one of those things it's up in the
air we're just gonna see what Bungie
does but uh another thing about the road
map is that uh I actually I like the
road map but I I don't like it at the
same time this is all I need all I need
you to tell me is hey
um new Season's gonna come out this time
that's all I know that's all I need
because I feel like whenever you start
putting a timer on things people start
complaining more because they like uh
it's like
if Bungie knows that there's going to be
a month of no content and they tell
people that or it's like here's a road
map and it's like well there's a gap
here and there's no content here people
will be more uh likely to you know voice
it and they're pretty much preparing to
be kind of uh upset and and like in a
way or just like they're they're
preparing to not play the game in a
sense where as like if there wasn't a
road map or if you just said hey like
this is when the DLCs are going to come
out or this is when I guess they're not
called Seasons
um I feel like people wouldn't be as you
know in in in inclined to quick to quit
so quickly you know
um I like road maps but at the same time
I don't want to know everything like the
secrecy that that mystery not getting
shot yo shout out to was it agony
fantastic Point
um he said while I think the issue is
it's a seven-year-old game and we've
done everything but whenever new stuff
is introduced we have to rerun all the
old stuff we need yeah that's a valid
point that's starting to really run its
course yes I mean how many more times
you're gonna be like hey with Solstice
you gotta go run strikes you gotta go
run gamut go do this other stuff it's
not like you see like a Borderlands DLC
totally new story comes out like our
story in this game is so drip fed it
hurts sometimes yeah I like like the
fact that we've had this like narrative
through line during the shadow season
the pyramids and Saint 14's here there
have been things that have happened
but it's like here's this little thing
here's this little thing if the season's
almost just like dropped it like just a
dump it in your lap go experience all of
it as like the baby expansions type
stuff it's so they want to keep people
coming back but it it almost hurts it so
much that they keep you coming back
because you feel like if you leave
you're gonna miss something but if you
stay around you're like I'm doing the
same thing crap right I'm not gonna say
the other word that was in my mind but
no you're right I mean I think Agony is
over there in agony because
I had to say that I thought of it I love
it I love it uh like please the prophecy
we all had to go grind for hours and
bounties preparation for something brand
new and it was shattered by old content
yeah I was like so like prophecy it was
such a high level you'd be like oh
everybody go do your bounties and grind
and all this other stuff that comes out
bam
right
no no no that's real that's right it's
like you have to grind old content to
get new content and at the same time
that new content stuff probably is isn't
even gonna uh matter like I think one of
the biggest things that I've heard about
Destiny is that there's so much to do
but in a sense it's all the same stuff
so none of it even really matters
because the reward for the stuff that
you're getting is something you've
already gotten in the past even if it's
a brand new weapon it's still the same
archetype there's still probably a
weapon that's better than it unless it's
you know like a pinnacle weapon that
we're just extremely broken which I
actually found to be very fun I actually
really enjoyed Pinnacle weapons and the
broken the Brokenness of them because
like and I personally I hate ritual
weapons I I don't like racial weapons
throwing knife was cool like but like I
literally like like I even like talked
about this in a video it was like a 12
minute video of me just ranting of how
much I hated ritual weapons and how the
fact that Pinnacle weapons were part of
the in-game activity because like once
you were kind of done with everything
for That season it's like okay now let's
go grind this penis
it was well worth the grind like yeah
the the the the the grind kept you
engaged and then the gun itself was like
oh my goodness like like recluse like
this thing is broken it's it's the the
fun Factor was there the grind was there
uh everything was there and it's just
like we don't we don't really get that
anymore yeah and then they get safe and
then they go oh well you know we
realized this was too hard so now we're
gonna do this and now we're gonna take
them out and it's just like bro like
that again
you know it's just like trying to
protect you and it's just like that's
the fun stuff like seeing your
especially with you right that recluse
video like it really did something for
you you know what I'm saying like it it
it's it's because it's a high level
dominant kind of weapon right that's
gonna force you to get in this activity
in comp and and and grind and get your
nose to the grindstone and work if you
want this yeah you know what I'm saying
I missed that like I love that aspect of
it because it's like if you want it
you're gonna have to put in the work and
and the reward was worthy like yo this
this wasn't Master of Arms it's crazy
like it's so much like I I love those
type of moments and they shouldn't shy
away from it they shouldn't you know and
just you know sometimes I feel that it
becomes a point where it's like
you know the vocal I don't say minority
but maybe majority where it's like maybe
they look at the base and they say okay
we're the you know hardcore so we're
just smaller percentage where there's
most people that can't acquire it and I
think a lot of times they kind of fall
towards that and they say well not
everybody's going to get it so we got to
bring the requirements down don't do
that bust the hell out of me no because
if you cater to the casuals the
hardcores are leaving the hard courser
would keep other people playing
thanks yes I mean and you guys are all
saying in chat too new red man oh shout
out to you by the way if you guys
haven't followed manodestra 777 YouTube
twitch awesome dude
um they're all saying it though like
level the fact that we did a thousand
bounties new content was boring we also
had the the prophecy cheese and also the
the grinding of the AFK Ford if we're
AFK Forge farming something's wrong
leveling is your AFK Forge farming and
that's the thing is like you need
content that facilitates the level Gap
otherwise no we're just doing the same
stuff like I would much rather be like
hey you're 1060. cool here's new stuff
for you to go do this is like if you're
not 1060 yet
okay you can't go do it yet but if you
are cool it's yours like the leveling
during the seasons
feels so forced
it feels like yeah you just gotta go
play through you got to do your
powerfuls you gotta do your Pinnacles
and everybody raids a lot and they like
they make you do all this stuff but I
think that might be what's burning some
of us out if I got to log in and I
didn't didn't have to go raid but maybe
they added like something here added
something there this is like the
seasonal thing something to it that
actually made me want to play not to add
a number to my like the number can
change but if I don't care what happens
when I get there yeah see that's my
problem see my thing is you know
I've struggled with the fact that the
number of resets in the season right I
initially struggled with that but my
thing is like you're saying if they're
gonna do this whatever season now you're
gonna go back down to whatever power
level and you know whatever whatever
once you go above that hard soft cap
whatever it is right
I need to feel powerful for this grind
I'm doing but I need to feel power I'm
not gonna tell you like when you're I'm
1080 versus another guy that's like I'm
not feeling I'm tanking so I need to if
you gonna make me if I'm putting in this
work and I am grinding these bounties
and I'm doing this activity I'm logging
into this game every week right and I'm
getting things done I need to feel like
a boss what I'm doing you're going to
you go into a raid you go into a
Vanguard strike you feel the same lover
powerful no no matter what number is on
that character now you can feel weaker
mind you you can get the yeah kicked out
of here real fast and that's the other
that's the other side of the equation
difficulty is not artificial High
numbers so just like oh I won shot you
in a grand master that's they're people
this season I'm I haven't got conquer
yet I need to try and find some people
who will willingly drag me through that
I'm high enough to get it but it just
sounds painful it is a title to go for
to say I you know some people have it
down to a fine art but again most people
when they talk about the corrupted and
then it was tree of probabilities no
right uh Garden of Salvation people just
hated running those under on Grand
Master because they're not fun one
little snipe one little trip up here
that that's not fun game mechanics
that's right everything that looks at
you wrong is gonna kill you rage and
agony's in my bag that's literally what
Eddie just said right now he says
nothing is I get bummed out how they're
doing all these promos and press and
make us feel powerful yes 750 Menagerie
we still get neutered in one shot by
nice see that's what I'm talking about
yeah I'm again D1 I miss going into an
old raid and going anything on what's up
and melting him and you're like yeah
like I miss that feeling because we it
feels good you're so powerful now now
it's like it's like a revenge tour it's
like yeah
yeah now you're gonna get it like I want
to feel like that why do they like I we
should be going in Leviathan right now
oh and absolutely like one shot again
yes ravaging callous yeah ravage that
sounds like a little dirty but that's
okay hey it is
last word after dark so yeah it's for
you guys it's after nine so that's fine
uh but no that's I mean I was I was
talking about this with literally one of
my buddies dildris who's out there
sometimes
um that's one of this one and then even
honestly Avengers is gonna run run into
the same thing if everything scales to
you you never feel powerful any like
World of Warcraft when I got to level
60. if I went back to a level 15 area I
would look at something and it would die
like not even like just blink Myers just
like screw this I'm dead nope not even
gonna try wow you can get killed in
patrols yes wow I am 1060. those patrols
are basically level one and I can still
get killed in there
like pick you up shot you down like
public events should not be a struggle
but they still make us do them so they
have to make them somewhat of an issue I
we've gone off on a tangent but it's a
valley leveling and they mentioned
they're trying to get away from bounties
I they haven't explained what that's
gonna be but I mean you can go do a
strike
and you can go do a raid and you'll
still get more so go expect get more
experience on a lost sector and bounties
yeah
you don't you don't get rewarded for
what you do and we don't feel powerful
and that's where if you don't feel
powerful on an RPG then none of those
numbers matter it takes away from the
fantasy and like I said I see guys with
insane light level numbers
like those guys should be like
11 20 or 30 some stupid number
uh and it's just like two things for
that guy one he's I think either just
going for a record or I think he said he
got to a certain point had to go back to
college so he's probably gonna get past
but those people are just like
constantly playing the same stuff over
and over and then the worst part is it's
Stripped Away
artifact leveling I'm honestly gonna be
okay if it's gone I don't mind if it's
gone but if it's gonna stay you better
make us feel powerful once we get past
that argument that's it if you're gonna
do this and keep stripping us down you
can't be scaling us that no there should
be a level of you know what I'm saying
once you get to a certain number cap
then that starts to depreciate it Delta
is yeah yeah it's like this yeah it's
not like this it's like it's like a one
degree tilt it ought to be a one degree
about 45 if you're gonna get over the
top so yeah and make how many people how
cool would it be for my file like you
know what I'm saying like his life's so
crazy now sharpering really benefits
because he's so powerful and it's just
like you know let me get these guys
people through you know what I'm saying
like that is fun that's gonna keep
people in keep the stream and then the
guys that are on the level be like all
right cool well I know my if I could get
down with him you know what I'm saying
like that
that'd be great that that would be great
like I know it says that like each each
Raider activity is like 750 base but and
I mean it doesn't I mean I'm sitting oh
over here like 10 75 and I I'm gonna get
killed in the same amount of shots as if
I was 750. yep and it it just really
sucks they I I yeah I know I do wish or
I do miss the uh the uh the the part of
just Destiny one like where you would
just go back and you would obliterate
everything and yes because I remember in
in the beta of B1 in the cosmodrome
where you'd land to the left there was
that little underground stairway
with the Knight that you couldn't kill
in the beta and then and when the full
game launched one of the first things I
did when I was of level I went down
there and I smacked that knife
yes he was like remember what you used
to do to me that's the feeling
around you're coming around in D1 that's
the feeling I missed that so bad man it
was so satisfying because we know the
pain that we went through dealing with
those areas and it felt so good it was
it was the ultimate revenge tour of like
yeah let's run that old Ray now I mean
that'd be a thing now it's like
prestigious Leviathan has been the game
for
three years
in forsaken we should have been able to
prestige Leviathan like okay you need to
go grind that thing out yeah you haven't
seen it before okay I can carry you
through it's a little harder a little
weird but you know
it's more then you're like learning
mechanics not dying to the same guys you
died to last year
no no it's
yeah it's like
I think we've definitely beaten to bed
yeah
but I mean it is one of those things
that this is one of those topics like if
we see another year this and we're
looking at you know 1260 infusion or
third what is it going to be no 1360 I
think is the big whatever it's going to
max out at the we can see and we're like
here's another 50 levels every time it's
it's one of those things about Destiny
that if it doesn't
evolve over the course of three more
years yeah that ninth year is gonna be
the end of it because people are gonna
be really tired of it yeah we'll have a
problem but like I said
I know we've been going in but one thing
about them
it's like it's a cycle they have to get
to that point where people get so fed up
and then they finally listen and they'll
be like yeah they're bad baby and they
have us in their honeymoon joint for
like another three to four months then
they mess up again it's a cycle we
tested it's just it's just how it is
I've come to accept it I'm not saying
it's right but I will say that I I'm
confident though for they're gonna do
their thing yeah it'll be hyped we'll be
back in pocket you know what I'm saying
and they will surprise us because
there's always those twabs eat when
we're watching we'll be like finally
this is
like version
I'm sorry like no crazy stuff
occasionally does happen yes yes agreed
okay it'll happen it just it just takes
them long and like you say you know like
you said my father you know I'm at the
point get your other games in we we know
how this cycle plays yeah do what you
got to do the yeah honey cycle that's
you know you know it's gonna be good
again you just come back and do your
thing just get everything else done I'm
working on ghost Shiva now at that last
point you know I'm saying Avengers is on
my bucket list Wasteland threes on my
bucket list I'm just trying to knock
everything out you know and in their
defense you know they needed more time
they delayed it because we would have
had it this is September it actually
would have been beyond light would have
technically dropped went like next week
or something 22nd or something like so
we did so it was still like six weeks so
a little yeah it had been a few weeks
later like and that's the thing too the
lore this season there's just gonna be
this pregnant pause until whatever
finishes that's enough I mean they've
had stuff coming in but are they going
to push the evacuation back or is the
evacuation gonna happen and then we just
have six weeks of nothing
he said it's like a toxic relationship
well you hope if they hang you hang on a
little longer they will change
cat is hilarious look it is what it is
man we know what we signed up for but um
they always do they think that's all I
got
yeah well man MiFi I'm so glad we got
you on here this has been it was good to
be on it was good to be on a blast so is
this your first podcaster you've been on
it oh this is my I mean back in like
high school like you know a few of my
friends
in the content creation world yeah this
is my first one
awesome it's my very first one awesome
thank you for letting us uh letting us
take you through it honestly it's been a
blast man it has been awesome yeah I
appreciate it
um sounds like we could keep rambling
like so apparently we have a lot of
stuff to complain about
tonight's Power as we talk about for 45
minutes
that's what but the floor is yours man
let them know what you got if you got
anything you're working on anything
you're playing where to find you what
you do we already kind of covered what
you do but I mean let them know the
floor is yours this is your time to tell
everybody who watches our stuff where to
find you uh so you can find me over on
YouTube literally just the name MiFi you
can look it up I'm currently taking a
little Hiatus I haven't uploaded in
about three weeks I'm pretty much kind
of just like
I'm just trying to like uh really focus
on like the twitch side of things uh
that's where that's where I'm gonna be
mainly at until be online drop switch.tv
slash my five with an underscore at the
end because twitch refuses to give me
the normal uh name Wi-Fi because it is
one person I looked it up too it's like
oh crap I mistyped it there's like one
person on that channel yep yep yep they
refused to give it to me
um and uh yeah so you gotta throw in the
underscore at the end or I will not come
up uh you'll catch me playing Destiny
over there uh Monday uh Monday Wednesday
uh Friday and Sundays now um I normally
just do Sherpas and help and just chill
out every now and then we'll hop over to
a different game whatnot but on the
YouTube whenever Beyond light does come
out we just post up build videos uh top
fives God roles stuff like that just
just trying to keep it interesting and
fun and whatnot and uh as of right now
man I mean I'm experimenting with other
games I'm only playing Destiny on stream
and off stream I'm playing other games
I'm currently playing through Spider-Man
on piano foreign
shots of Glory yes yes yes we do
absolutely man yo but yeah that's pretty
much what I got going on that's what's
up man yeah absolute pleasure to have
you in man like you killed it the
pleasure being here salute I don't have
this on your first podcast you know as a
content creator so salute for you coming
through on that love the content love
what you're doing shout out to the beach
it beats be rocket by the way I was
reading the shots out on your Beats
doing your stream stuff right you'll be
getting it in I'll be liking the music
in the background
some alternative rock a lot of Rock game
is lit I was like oh what's that okay
but like I went there I typed in 2000's
rock Essentials played the playlist it's
three hours long and I would have to
keep looping it so my mod uh shazz
really like probably one of my best
friends
said all right he takes the playlist he
makes he takes it finds similar songs
and turns it into a nine hour playlist
and then he went and I got a hip-hop one
of like rap and when I only listen to
Rob I only listen to rock on stream off
stream I listen like rap and hip-hop so
he made like a nine hour playlist that I
don't even use on stream I just used it
off stream and it's just like but no
when it comes to playing music like
copywriting music on Twitch what you
want to do is that you just want to turn
off Clips
um when it comes to Vibes vods get muted
but uh Clips I I feel pretty safe uh
with my Clips turned off and my vodge
just automatically get muted so yeah
yeah it's just like because I mean it
was like Spotify and then I'd pull it be
like oh I was like going through like
nostalgic music like random Mega Man
stuff or playing through rich just like
it was fun to mess around with music
especially if you're grinding stuff out
like yeah that is one of those things
that like I wanted to so it's like
that's good to know on the clips and
stuff that you've been saying I just I
shut everything off when all those
people like when the dmca strikes were
coming out and all that stuff for twitch
so it's just trying to be safe and I saw
some people are still doing it so I was
like yeah it feels a little better to
get back in I guess plus I I just can't
Vibe with like like all that royalty
free music like I haven't found any that
I like man like I mean I tried uh
I I uh like it was like one night like
uh like glad wasn't streaming I went
there I typed in playlist and it was
like his dmca uh free place I loaded I
was like you know these are good but
like I just can't get away from just
like my my main like oh yeah smells like
I listen to and and it's just like the
the like the stream Vibes just like
weren't as high whatever the music's
just not right and I'm which I just
couldn't do it anymore I did the same
thing as well but I mean that the whole
dmca thing happened a few uh years back
and uh people freaked out and started
playing non-copyrighted music and then
after you know about half a year it kind
of simmers down it goes back to normal
pretty much anytime like a big streamer
gets hit with like a dmca takedown
people freak out but then they kind of
simmer back down and kind of go back to
normal until twitch gets fully kind of
uh like copyright uh like things get put
in place we're automatic like you know
strikes and uh uh removals and stuff
like that happen but yeah I gotta shot
your motto so Shaz is the real one
salute the shadow I love shots I
wouldn't do half the things I did if if
he wasn't helping me out yeah no but yes
I got a solution right now keep up the
ground salute to the mods out there you
guys are the unsung heroes unsung heroes
for real man but yeah
you see it tonight but yeah you already
know me man at La Cognito on Twitter I
don't know a podcast every Sunday is the
Lord's Day check us out and uh Lords
gaming.net man we really doing some big
things with the website just got
approved to open critic you know what
I'm saying so super proud of the team
got some stuff cooking up with the site
that you're gonna see and uh this Sunday
we got a big one y'all so show some love
Island podcast this Sunday the legendary
Ryan McCaffrey will be in the building
that's podcast a lot igno filtered the
whole thing Sunday 1 pm if you can't
catch it on YouTube catch us live on
Twitch as well we do the restream over
there so this is a big one in the cap
you know you know the intro gonna be lit
and we're gonna have some fun man so
yeah that intro is going to be five
minutes long yeah we go we're gonna hit
him we're gonna hit him hard like how we
hit my fire
so let's go let's go so check us out
appreciate your support it's been it's
been tremendous so uh check us out there
man that's all I got yeah uh well again
wife I thank you man got a shout out
Cognito the Mr Holly podcast man he's
bouncing around all the big podcast
names he's got another one the destiny
show coming up later a couple IGN guest
appearance this man is everywhere
no I was like I'm bound down right now
this man this podcast greatness so no
shout out to my co-host but senior my
fight
man this is fun okay like the tangents
we get off on sometimes I never know how
they're gonna go but just you jumping
right in thank you thank you very much
everybody in chat you guys have been
amazing shout out to Shaz apparently
you're the unsung hero of the MiFi
twitch Channel
and to everybody in my chat as well all
you guys you know lots of love out there
so for me you guys know where to find me
I've been streaming Adventures playing
that one see how long that one will hold
my attention of course you guys know
where to find me on Twitch and Twitter
tibontus everywhere YouTube's of course
still grown and stuff thank you guys not
as big as MiFi out here but we're always
uh we're always trying to chase the
bigger creators than us so doing
everything we can uh but we know beyond
light's gonna be big so best thing I can
say is like take your break try these
other games that you haven't played play
Avengers go play God of War if you
haven't breathe a little bit yes and
then when when you know when you get
back to Destiny it's probably gonna feel
a little better
um
man sweet okay so we get I made through
so far I'm safe
yep don't say anything so Jason
all right so uh well thank you man very
much make sure you guys go follow my
fight on Twitch on Twitter on YouTube
find him Lord Cognito the podcast iron
lord lord of gaming man and for me ivont
is everywhere uh thank you guys very
much I'm gonna send you guys over to
Raider Channel we'll do that in a second
but for episode number 119 September 4th
thank you guys very much and it has been
the last word with a siren in the back
so it's like we'll do it again so
whenever I have that pause just say it's
been the last damn siren came in I'm
like come on so it has been
the last last word